K. THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE HEARING TO ORDER- WE
ARE GOING TO START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE- SO WELCOME TO
APRIL FIFTH HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL
THE STAFF. OF A POSSIBLE OUR
ABILITY TO MAXIMIZE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SAY
PARTICIPATION IN OUR HEARINGS TO
THAT END ALL NOW SHARE A FEW
NOTES ABOUT THE LOGISTICS OF OUR
HEARING TODAY. REGARDING PUBLICS
ASK ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION FOR
THOSE JOINING US IN PERSON FACE
COVERINGS ARE ENCOURAGED FOR ALL
MEMBERS EMPLOYEES AND THE PUBLIC
IN ALL COMMON AREAS AND SHARED
SPACES- FOR DIALING WITNESSES
WILL BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL IS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOUR CALL PLANNING ON
CALLING I PLEASE DO SO NOW. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. WHEN CALLING IN PLEASE
BE MINDFUL. AND ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE. LASTLY A BIKE
TO ADDRESS JUST A QUICK NOTE
ABOUT DISRUPTIONS ANY CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPTS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THIS HEARING IS PROHIBITED IF
DISRUPTIVE BEHAVIOR OCCURS TODAY
YOU'LL BE REMOVED FROM THE
HEARING ROOM BY THE ASSEMBLY
SERGEANTS OR YOU'LL BE REMOVED
FROM THE CALL. OKAY SO ONCE WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM WE'RE
NOT THERE YET- BUT WE HAVE
TWENTY ONE BILLS ON THE AGENDA.
TEN OF WHICH ARE ON CONSENT AND
PLEASE NOTE THAT WE WILL LIMIT
TESTIMONY TO TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. AND TWO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION EACH WITNESS WILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES TO TESTIFY. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES MAY ADD ON
BY CITY STATING THEIR NAME AND
AFFILIATION AND THAT SET. OKAY-
OKAY. GREAT SO.
OKAY SOMEONE COOLEY- WHICH YOU
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE EARLY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT ON
TWENTY THREE SO SIX YES OKAY
YOU'RE WELCOME. EXPLORE GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB TWO THREE OH SIX THIS
BILL RELATES TO FOSTER YOUTH
FOSTER CARE IN ADDRESSES GAPS TO
CONTINUE CONTINUUM OF CARE
REFORM- AND WILL HELP CALIFORNIA
MEET THE FEDERAL FAMILIES FIRST
PREVENTION SERVICES ACT- AND
IT'S REQUIREMENTS WILL ALSO
UPDATE EXPAND THE INDEPENDENT
LIVING PROGRAM. EXPANDS OUR
CURRENT FOSTER FAMILY HOME IS
SMALL FAMILY HOME INSURANCE FUND
PROGRAM BY TERRIFYING CLAIMING
RULES UNDER LICENSING RULES THAT
TOOK EFFECT LAST OCTOBER
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PLACEMENT
PROGRAM FOR MINORS PHIL ST THE
NEW TITLE FOR- DASH E. FUNDING
REQUIREMENTS AS AN ELIGIBLE
FACILITY. UNDER THE- F. F. P. S.
A PROGRAM FAMILIES FIRST
PREVENTION SERVICES ACT. TO
ENSURE THESE CALIFORNIA FOSTER
YOUTH RECEIVE THE SUPPORT THEY
NEED THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES TO
DEVELOP RECOMMENDATIONS FOR A
NEW LICENSING CATEGORY OF
SPECIALIZED FOSTER HOMES. FOR
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH FROM
SIXTEEN TO TWENTY ONE YEARS OF
AGE. AND I DO WANTTO EMPHASIZE
THAT THAT THAT MEANS THAT. EVEN
AS OUR FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
INVOLVES A PARTNERSHIP THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THIS BILL
REALLY REQUIRES A PARTNERSHIP
WITH DSS TO KINDA HELP US. FLUSH
OUT A PRO THAT CONFORMS TO
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS. ON THE
SOCIAL SERVICE RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES PROVIDING BOARD CARE
AND SUPERVISION BY RESOURCE
PARENT. STANDARD FOR THESE HOMES
WILL AS I MENTIONED WE DEVELOPED
UNDER DSS- COUNTY PLACE NEEDS
HIS FOSTER YOUTH INTERESTED
STAKEHOLDERS OR COLLABORATIVE
PROCESS. THE BILL ALSO ENSURES
THAT THE SPECIALIZED FOSTER
HOMES MEET REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
AID TO FAMILIES WITH DEPENDENT
CHILDREN FOSTER CARE PROGRAM. OF
THE FF PSA ALSO ALLOW STATES
THAT HAVE EXTENDED THEIR FOSTER
CARE PROGRAMS. TO DISTASTE IN
THEIR CHAFEE INDEPENDENT LIVING
PROGRAMS UP TO AGE TWENTY THREE
WHICH CALIFORNIA HAD NOT YET
OPTED TO DO. THIS BILL EXPANDS
ITS EXISTING I'LL P. TO AGE
TWENTY THREE- DEPENDING UPON
AVAILABLE FUNDING. AND REQUIRES
DSS TO UPDATE I'LL P. STANDARDS
STATEWIDE IN COLLABORATION WITH
COUNTIES FOR SHOOT AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS SO AGAIN DEPEND
UPON WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
DSS. IN A DISTRICTS IN THE AISLE
PH CAP THIS BILL LEADS TO
EXPECTATIONS FOR THE IOP
PROGRAMS. TO INCLUDE SUPPORT FOR
BUILDING AND MAINTAINING FAMILY
FAMILY LIKE AN ADULT
CONNECTIONS. AND ACCESS TO
SUPPORT FOR POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION TO ACHIEVE VOCATIONAL
GOALS SELF. REALLY LOOK AT HOW
DO YOU. EQUIP CHILDREN. IT
EMOTIONALLY FAMILY WINES. BUT
SKILL WISE TO KIND OF- ENTER
INTO ADULT LIFE AS PRODUCTIVE
AND CONTRIBUTING INDIVIDUALS-
WITH ALL THE SELF ESTEEM THAT
THAT ENTAILS. FINALLY GASSMAN
RECOGNIZE INSISTS YOU ARE
REGARDING THE FOSTER FAMILY HOME
AND SMALL FAMILY HOME INSURANCE
FUND. THAT PROGRAM DOES NOT
SPECIFY TERMS GOVERNMENT
REIMBURSEMENT CLAIMS ARISING FOR
PROPERTY DAMAGE. NOR DOES IT
SUPPORT FOSTER CARE GIVERS WHEN
THEY FACE LEGAL CHALLENGES IN
THE CARE OF FOSTER YOUTH. THIS
BILL AUTHORIZES THE FOSTER
FAMILY HOMES SMALL FAMILY HOME
INSURANCE FUNDS TO MAKE PAYMENTS
ON BEHALF OF SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPY PROGRAMS.
AND REQUIRES A FUND REIMBURSED
CLAIMS ARISE OUT OF PROPERTY
DAMAGE IF DAMAGES ARE LESS THAN
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS. OF THE
BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
HAS RECEIVED BILL OPPOSITION.
THOUGH OF COURSE. IN RELIANCE
UPON DSS STILL BE ONGOING
CONVERSATION WITH HIM THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS AND MY FRIEND SAID
IS BEEN. BOTH TYPICAL AND
PRODUCTIVE- AND I'M HONORED TO
HAVE PAUL OF ALASKA'S DIRECTOR
OF LEGISLATION OF COUNTY WELFARE
DRIPS BOAT ASSOCIATES BEGAN
SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU MR
COOLEY GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M PAULA
VAZQUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE PROUD TO BE
THE SPONSORS. OF AB TWENTY THREE
OH SIX WHICH WAS JUST VERY WELL
OUTLINED BY A FAMILY MEMBER
COOLEY IT WOULD SUPPORT- HOUSING
OPTIONS FOR TRANSITION AGE
FOSTER YOUTH OTHERWISE REFERRED
TO AS- K. AND HELP STABILIZE
FOSTER CARE PLACEMENTS. THERE
ARE THREE COMPONENTS- THAT MAKE
UP AB TWENTY THREE OH SIX IN THE
FIRST IS THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A
NEW LICENSING CATEGORY KNOWN AS
A SPECIALIZED FOSTER HOME. FOR
TRANSITION AGE YUTH THE SECOND
IS THE MODERNIZATION AND
EXPANSION OF THE INDEPENDENT
LIVING PROGRAM AND THE THIRD IS
EXPANDING THE CURRENT FOSTER
FAMILY HOME AND SMALL FAMILY
HOME. INSURANCE FUND FOR THE
FIRST COMPONENT AB TWENTY THREE
OH SIX ESTABLISHES A NEW
RESIDENTIAL OPTION FOR
TRANSITION AGE FOSTER YOUTH.
THAT CONFORMS TO THE
REQUIREMENTS ESTABLISHED BY THE
PHONE FEDERAL FAMILY FIRST
PREVENTION SERVICES ACT AFFECT
PSA AND LEVERAGES FEDERAL PATENT
FORTY FUNDING. THIS WILL PROVIDE
COUNTY PUT UP PLACING AGENCIES
AND FOSTER YOU WITH FOSTER YOUTH
WITH AN ALTERNATIVE MODEL FROM
THE CURRENT TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PLACEMENT PROGRAM FOR MINORS
PROGRAM. WHICH HAS PROVEN TO BE
AN EFFECTIVE PROGRAM FOR OLDER
FOSTER YOUTH TRANSITIONING INTO
ADULTHOOD. AS NOTED BY MR COOLEY
UNDER ITS CURRENTLY LICENSE.
CURRENTLY LIFE INSTRUCTURE TEACH
PPM DOES NOT MEET YOUR
REQUIREMENTS UNDER AFFECT PSA.
THEREFORE WE RISK LOSING OUT ON
MAXIMIZING FEDERAL FUNDING AND
PREVENTING YOU FROM BENEFITING
FROM. THIS PROGRAM THE SECOND
COMPONENT MODERNIZES THE IOP
PROGRAM. THE IOP PROGRAM
PROVIDES IMPORTANT SERVICES AND
BENEFITS TO FIX CURRENT AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. IN
ACHIEVING GREATER SELF
SUFFICIENCY PRIOR TO AND AFTER
LEAVING THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
RECENT CHANGES TO FEDERAL LAW
ALLOW FOR I'LL BE SERVICES UP TO
TWENTY THREE YEARS OF AGE. FOR
STATE THAT HAVE EXTENDED THEIR
FOSTER PARK CARE PROGRAM AS
CALIFORNIA HAS DONE. CALIFORNIAN
AUTHORED EIGHT THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED NON MINOR DEPENDENTS IN
THE EXTENDED FOSTER CARE PROGRAM
BUT HAVE NOT MADE CHANGES TO THE
IOP. PROGRAM TO SERVE THESE
YOUNG ADULTS WHICH IS WHAT THIS
BILL SEEKS TO DO. LASTLY IF
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
IMPLEMENT THE C. R. AND PROMOTE
FAMILY BASED AND COMMUNITY BASED
CARE ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS ARE
NEEDED FOR RESOURCE FAMILY AND
OTHER FOSTER CARE PROVIDERS TO
INCLUDE PROTECTION FROM PERSONAL
AND PROPERTY. LIABILITY TO THOSE
CARE GIVERS SO THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE FAMILY BASED CARE GIVERS
AS WELL AS SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS
KNOWN AS S. T. R. T. P.'S.
PREPARE FOR MOST TRAUMATIZED
FOSTER FOSTER YOUTH WITH GREATER
SUPPORT TO MEET THE YOUTH NEEDS
PARTICULARLY WHEN FOSTER YOUTH.
MAY DISPLAY TREMENDOUS BEHAVIORS
IN THE HOME OR OTHER SETTINGS
THAT RESULT IN DAMAGE TO THE
HOME. AB TWENTY ZERO SIX TAKE
SIGNIFICANT POSITIVE STEPS TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR CONDITIONS
FOSTER YOUTH AND HELP STABILIZE
THE PLACEMENT THANK YOU MR
COOLEY FOR OFFERINGS IMPORTANT
BILL AND THANK YOU AS WELL TO
COMMITTEE STAFFER THE THOUGHTFUL
REVIEW OF THE BILL. FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR POSITIVE CONSIDERATION OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU- OKAY I
THINK WE ONLY HAVE ONE WITNESS
CORRECT SO- NOW I'M GOING TO
OPEN IT UP FOR ANY. ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM- DO WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT IN THE
ROOM. OKAY SCENE NINE- OPERATOR
TO HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT-
ON THE PHONES COULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE. YES LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE GET LINE NUMBERS
ASSIGNED. ONCE AGAIN ANYBODY WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE ZERO SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AND FIRST WE'LL GO TO LINE.
TWELVE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS CHANGING THEIR
FROM THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER WERE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AND NEXT WE HAVE THE LINE
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BARBARA TO
ANNIHILATE POSED AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE. OKAY THANK YOU WELL WE'RE
ON A. B. TWO THREE ZERO SIX
RIGHT NOW. RIGHT. THANK YOU AND
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK
YOU THANK YOU OPERATOR YOU ARE
NOW I'D LIKE TO ASK IF THERE IS
ANY OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM.
CASEY NINE OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION- ON THE LINE. N.
AS IN GERMAN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF AB. TWO
THREE ZERO SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND. WE HAVE NINE
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS LAURA
RETURN AND I DO OPPOSE A. B. TWO
TWO TWO THREE OKAY THANKS OKAY
AT A DIFFERENT THAT'S A
DIFFERENT TELL YES. THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
THANK YOU UNTIL OKAY- DO WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. CHARAKA RETURNS
WE CAN'T WE CAN'T MOVE FORWARD
WITHOUT QUORUM SO- WE WILL VOTE
ON YOUR BELT YOU WANNA. LOWS MR
COOLEY BOOK COLLEAGUES I A IT'S
ALWAYS A PLEASURE BEING HERE.
AND I KNOW- WHEN I AM IN IN THIS
COMMITTEE IT'S LIKE YOU HEAR A
LOT OF ACRONYMS. AND THEY CAN BE%
SORT OF DRY ABSTRACT BUT
ACTUALLY- THEY ALL REPRESENT
PROGRAMS OR TOUCH PEOPLE'S LIVES
CONCRETE TANGIBLE BENEFICIAL
WAYS. SO I AM PEASED TO BRING
YOU A BILL THAT IT RELATES TO
ANOTHER SET OF ACRONYMS I THINK
THE COURTESY OF THE HEARING IT
THANK YOU FOR THE CONSIDERATION.
AND IN THE SPIRIT OF THIS ROOM I
WOULD JUST SAY. AS A COLLEAGUES
ARRIVE A HOPE ALL WILL BE A OKAY
. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU'RE
WELCOME THANK YOU THANK A MEMBER
COOLEY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VIA PLAZA WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PRESENT YOUR BILL
NOW. OKAY.
YEAH FROM. DEAD LAST AT. SECOND.
OKAY THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS AB
TWENTY FORTY TWO CAN YOU HEAR ME
. WILL INCREASE AWARENESS FOR
THE SIGNS OF SYMPTOMS OF
ANAPHYLAXIS. A SERVICE A SERVER
A POTENTIALLY LIFE THREATENING
ALLERGY REACTION IN CHILDCARE
SETTINGS INFANTS AND TODDLERS
ARE PARTICULARLY AT RISK AS THE
RATE OF ANAPHYLAXIS IS MUCH
HIGHER AMONG THESE THIS AGE
GROUP AND WITHOUT PROPER
TRAINING RECOGNIZING THE SIGNS
AND SYMPTOMS CAN PROVE MORE
DIFFICULT THE TRAINING COMPELLED
BY AB TWENTY FORTY TWO IS A
SIMPLE ENHANCEMENT FOR OF THE
FIRST AID CPR TRAINING ONE MUST
ALREADY GET TODAY AS A
CONDITION. OF ONE OF THE CHILD
CARE LICENSE. THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT CHILDREN. THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT CHILD CARE PROVIDERS WILL
HAVE THE BEST PRACTICE POLICY IN
PLACE TO PREVENT ANAPHYLAXIS THE
TRAINING TO RECOGNIZE SIGNS
SYMPTOMS AND SHOULD BE AN ABBOTT
ANAPHYLACTIC EVENT OCCUR. THE
COULD THE CAPACITY TO TREAT. K.
THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS ARE
READY A FULL UP AFFORDED
PROTECTION FROM THE ANAPHYLAXIS
WE SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT THE
MOST MODERN VULNERABLE OF OUR
PATIENTS THAT BEING INFANTS
TODDLERS OR ARE AFFORDED THE
SAME WHEN BEING CARED FOR IN
CHILD CARE SETTINGS WITH ME
TODAY BY PHONE IN PERSON TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FORTY TWO. IN N. OUR SPONSORS IS
THOMAS SILVEIRA FOUNDER OF THE
ELIJAH ALTHEA FOUNDATION AND-
JOANNE GIORGI FOUNDER OF THE
BOARD OF BOARD MEMBERS AND
D'ITALIA GEORGIE SUNSHINE
FOUNDATION. OKAY THANK YOU- ED
CHAU N. G. R. TO FEEL LIKE TO GO
FIRST TO MY DEFENSE I THINK-
PLEASE STAND UP THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME MY NAME IS
JOANNE GEORGIE I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT AND CO FOUNDER OF THE
NATURAL G. SUNSHINE FOUNDATION
OUR FOUNDATION WAS ESTABLISHED
IN MEMORY OF OUR DAUGHTER
NATALIE WHO TRAGICALLY DIED AT
CAMP SACRAMENTO IN JULY OF TWO
THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN AFTER
ACCIDENTALLY INGESTING A RICE
KRISPY TREAT THAT UNKNOWINGLY
HAD PEANUT BUTTER IN IT. TODAY
I'M HERE TO LEND MY SUPPORT AB
TWENTY FORTY TO ANALYZE HIS
MEMORY THE BILL WILL PROTECT THE
YOUNGEST MEMBERS OF OUR STATE IT
WILL PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
TRAINING AND EDUCATION REGARDING
ANAPHYLAXIS AND FOOD ALLERGIES
TO OUR CHILD CARE FACILITIES OUR
FAMILY BEGAN. IN. TWO THOUSAND
AND FOURTEEN ABOUT SIX. ASKED
AWAY. WE WERE. SUPPORT AT CLAM
SIXTY WHICH ABOUT. THINK NEED TO
HAPPEN AT IN OUR CASE. PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. AGAIN THE NINETEEN WE
ADVOCATED FOR REST LEGISLATION
THAT ADDRESSED FOOD ALLERGIES
AND- I MEAN STAFF TO BE TRAINED
ON. THIS LAW KNOWN AS NATALIE'S
LIFE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
SHOWN THEIR UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
FOR FOOD ALLERGY LIKE REACTIONS
IN THE PAST I KNOW THAT THAT
WILL CONTINUE. WE STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL YOU
WILL SAVE A LIFE IT IS MY
SINCERE HOPE THAT I DON'T EVER
HAVE TO COME BACK TO THIS TABLE
WITH ANOTHER PICTURE OF A
PRECIOUS CHILD WHOSE LIFE WAS
TAKEN TOO SOON BY FOOD
ALLERGIES. AB TWENTY FORTY TWO
ANALYZES MEMORY WILL PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES AND TRAINING TO
PROTECT OUR YOUNGEST CHILDREN IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF MY FAMILY AND OUR
SUNSHINE GIRLS WE ASK YOU TO
PLEASE SUPPORT AB TWENTY FORTY
TWO. ALLIES AS WELL. YOU I THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE I THINK-
OPERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR THE NEXT WITNESS IN
SUPPORT THOMAS OF ERA. BOB.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YES GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SH HI
HI EVERYBODY THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR TAKING THE TIME OUT OF YOUR
BUSY SCHEDULE TODAY I KNOW IT'S
AN IMPORTANT DAY FOR EVERYONE. I
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS THAT IT ON
NOVEMBER THIRD TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
MY ON'S LIFE WAS TRAGICALLY
TAKEN FROM THEM. AND WE ALL KNOW
THAT CHAU CHILDHOOD FOOD
ALLERGIES CAN BE SERIOUS. AND
THEY'RE TO BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY
BECAUSE IT'S NOT. CHILDREN CAN
DIE. IN A MICHAELIDES WAS ONLY
THREE HE NEEDED. THE ADULT CHILD
CARE. TO TAKE ITS WAY OUT OF THE
SERIOUSLY AND THEY GET IN. AND
HE DIED. BECAUSE OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF MY SON'S DEATH.
ISSUE LIVED LIFE HAD TO HAVE
IGNITED A IN MY FAMILY TO
ENSURE. THERE POLICIES AND
GUIDANCE IN PLACE TO PROTECT
CHILDREN AS PORTABLE AS HE WAS
WITH SEVERE FOOD ALLERGIES. AND
WE KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA WITH THE
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FORTY TWO
CAN DO THAT. CAVE AND LYFT.
MEANS THE- ESPECIALLY IF THE
MOST PRECIOUS CHILDREN INCLUDING
THE POLICY THE GUYS IN PLACE
WILL GIVE PEACE OF MIND TO
PARENTS DROPPING THE KIDS OFF AT
SCHOOL KNOWING THAT THE
EDUCATORS ARE FULLY AWARE AND
TRAINED. BY UNDERSTANDING THE
SIZE SYMPTOMS MITIGATING RISK
AND BEING ABLE TO WORK SWIFTLY
AND- CALIFORNIA TO IDENTIFY
REACTED. AND YOUR ONE STANDING
THERE WILL THE PICTURE MY SON.
AND ME BEING THREE MAH AWAY.
BECAUSE I CANNOT BE THERE. IT
JUST SAYS THAT THE POWER OF ONE
IS BIG VALUE TO THE PUBLIC MANY
CAN DO A CREATE CHANGE. AND I
ACTUALLY UPPORT ON AB. TWENTY
FOURTEEN TO FOUR. OKAY. THANK
YOU. CAN I WOULD A DISH SUPPORT
- IN THE ROOM FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. OKAY SAY
NINE OPERATE COULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE THERE'S ANYBODY
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FORTY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AND FIRST WE HAVE
LINE THIRTEEN FORTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIRTEEN FORTY THREE
OR MINUS OPEN.
ALL RIGHT. NINE THIRTEEN FORTY
THREE AND- NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWELVE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWELVE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO FIND TWELVE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE NEXT NEXT LINE OPERATOR
PLEASE I'M SORRY WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN KILL OKAY THANK YOU. DO
WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION AS
ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY.
BY IN OPPOSITION. IN THE ROOM HI
KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER WITH US
YEAH YOU WERE NOT OPPOSE WE JUST
HAVE SOME CONCERNS WERE TWEENER
WITHOUT A FORMAL POSITION WE'VE
BEEN REVIEWING IT AND WE
REPRESENT- PROVIDERS IN FAMILY
CHILD CARE AS WELL AS CENTERS
AND WE'RE JUST CONCERNED ABOUT
THE IMPACT ON THE WORKERS- THEY
DON'T HAVE PROFESSIONAL TRAINING
AT THIS MOMENT CALIFORNIA AND
FEDERALLY- IS STILL IS WERE
REQUIRED TO HAVE A PRESCRIPTION
TO HAVE AN EPIPEN UNLESS YOU
HAVE A SCHOOL. WHERE THERE ARE
NURSES AND OTHER HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONAL A LOT OF THESE
FACILITIES CENTERS BUT
ESPECIALLY FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS OPERATE OUT OF THEIR
HOME DON'T HAVE THE EXPERTISE
THEY DON'T HAVE EIGHT YEARS THEY
DON'T KNOW THE DOSAGE- THEY'RE
GOING TO BE GAS. OUR CONCERN- OF
CARE FOLLOW UP REQUIRED AND IT'S
JUST A LOT OF- JUST PUT ON A
PROVIDER- WE CURRENTLY ARE
ASKING FOR ALL TRAINING BUT IT'S
REQUIRED FOR PROVIDERS. I'M TO
BE REVIEWED AT THE MOMENT- SO
THIS JUST ADDS ON TRAINING
WITHOUT COMPENSATION TOOL-
WORKERS ARE ALREADY BREAKING
BELOW BUT- MINIMUM WAGE- SO
THOSE ARE THE CONCERNS WE HAVE
WE WOULD LIKE. TO REVIEW HOW WE
ADDRESS THE WORKING OUT OF
CLASSIFICATION. AND TO ALSO HAVE
ADDITIONAL TRAINING WITHOUT
COMPENSATION IN THE WORK FORCE
IS ALREADY. A VERY UNDERSTAFFED
AND UNDERFUNDED THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU. TO HAVE ANYBODY ELSE
IN THE ROOM. WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION NOW OKAY
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE SEE IF WE HAVE ANYBODY ON
THE LINE AND CUTE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THEY GIVEN
OPPOSITION I'VE AB TWENTY FORTY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN
THEY'RE OFF IN OPPOSITION. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE TWELVE NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWELVE NINETY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ARE YOU ABLE TO
HEAR US. OKAY BURGER MOVE ONTO.
LINE TWELVE IT'S SIXTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE NASTY FOR A YEAR ON
BEHALF AT THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
AND COURT EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
WE HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION GREEN REPRESENTS
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES AND ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE LACK OF PROTECTION THE BILL
HAS FOR CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OPERATOR
TO HAVE ANYONE TO LOOK LIKE.
THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ERIN HOW
WHEN AND I OPPOSE. AB. TWO TWO
TWO THREE. OKAY BROWN AB TWO
THAT WITH FOR. NEXT OKAY AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. OKAY THANK
YOU OPERATOR- NOW LET'S SEE IF
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY GO AHEAD THANK
YOU MANAGER A QUESTION REGARDS
TO THIS IS THERE DANGER OR ANY
SIDE EFFECTS IF THIS IS
MINISTERED WRONG. SUCH AS LIKE
NOW CAN'T YOU CAN'T DO ANY
DAMAGE WHEN YOU GIVEN OUR CAN TO
SOME THAT'S OVERDOSING AND JUST
CURIOUS ON THIS. WHICH JUST UP
TO YOU I. CAN OUT. I'M NOT A
PHYSICIAN- MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT NOW- THAT THERE ARE
DIFFERENT DOSAGES FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN PURSES WHEN CHILDREN
GET OLDER- THAT TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE SO CHILDREN DO NOT
RECEIVE THE MEDICATION MONTHLY-
THEY WILL DIE AND THAT WAS THE
CASE IN MY DAUGHTER AND- ELIJAH
WAS NOT ADMINISTERED AND WE BOTH
HAD THE UP AND A FRIEND AND- IN
HAND SO- I'M NOT A PHYSICIAN I
KNOW FROM WHAT PHYSICIANS HAVE
TOLD US IS THAT YOU CANNOT HARM
DONE BY GIVING A TO MEASURE DOES
THEY COME IN DIFFERENT FORMS-
YOU'VE HEARD ABBY PANS- ABI KEY
. IT'S A MEASURE DOES SO YOU
CAN'T GIVE THEM MY UNDERSTANDING
IS A FATAL DOSE IT'S FATAL IF
YOU DON'T ADMINISTER IT GENTLY
THANK YOU PATH. OKAY I DON'T SEE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE OUR WOULD SO. MEET
ME- ADDRESS IN SHORT IN
RESOLVING THIS GAP RIGHT. WE'RE
HOW DISTURBED KATE THROUGH
TWELVE. AND ALL I'M TRYING TO DO
IS CLOSE THAT GAP I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY- MY TO- PRESENTERS
TODAY. I WENT THROUGH A TRAGIC
IT WAS TRAGIC I'M TRYING TO
PREVENT THAT. KIND OF WE ARE WE
ARE GOING TO ADD TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE PROTECT THE LIABILITIES
FOR WORKERS- BUT MY OWN DAUGHTER
WENT THROUGH THIS AND- I DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO WHEN SHE TURNED.
YOU KNOW. PURPLE LUCKY THAT SHE
CAME OUT OF IT. SHE CAME OUT
SOMEHOW. I PANICKED I DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO. BUT I'M TRYING
TO PROTECT YOUR K<c.cyan> TRIALS</c>
ALREADY DONE IS THE GAP CLOSE
THAT GAP. BECAUSE OF THOSE THE
ONES WERE NOT THINKING ABOUT
THOSE ARE THE ONES MOST
VULNERABLE THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE PROTECTING THEM.
AND YOU KNOW I MEAN I NEVER KNEW
THAT I WAS GOING TO BE. YOU KNOW
TALKING ABOUT THIS BILL WHEN MY
OWN DAUGHTER WENT THROUGH IT
RIGHT I MEAN YOU KNOW YOU YOU
YOU YOU DON'T THINK ABOUT STUFF
THAT WE PASS APPEAR. BUT THIS
BILL NOW IS HAS BEING COME CLOSE
TO ME BECAUSE I SEEN MY OWN AND
TO SEE AND HEAR THIS TRAGIC
STORIES WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING.
BECAUSE ARE NOT PROTECTING THEM
AND THIS IS JUST TO PROTECT THEM
TO THAT WE DON'T HAVE WE DON'T
HAVE THE TRAGIC STORIES ANYMORE.
AT ALL I DO IS TRYING TO
PROTECT. THAT GROUP. SO WITH
THAT I ASKED AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SO A MEMBER AND I AND I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT. BUILT
ON BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND-
AND YOUR WILLINGNESS TO- YOU
KNOW. WORK THROUGH THIS- BECAUSE
I KNOW THAT YOU JUST WANT TO
PROTECT THAT THAT GROUP OF BILL
OKAY. AND- THE BILL- SO WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM SO WE WILL- VOTE
ON THIS LATER WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM THANK YOU AFTER. YES SOME
MEMBER GIPSON WITH YOU LIKE TO
PROVIDE. THIS IS AT AB. TWO
ZERO.
FIRST NAME IS A GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO THIRTY
WHICH SEEKS TO REDUCE THE
BARRIERS THAT HOMELESS FAMILIES
FACE IN GETTING. HOUSING
ASSISTANCE. BEFORE I CONTINUE I
WANT TO CONFIRM THAT I'VE
REVIEWED THE- COMMITTEE- AND-
ANALYSTS. OF ANNOUNCER THIS BILL
SKEWS ME AND I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS TO
CLARIFY WHAT WOULD IN AN
ACCIDENT OF HOMELESSNESS I
BELIEVE THAT THIS WAS THE ONLY
RECOMMENDATION THAT WAS MADE BY
THIS COMMITTEE THE CAL WORKS-
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IS A
BENEFIT- AVAILABLE IN ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. IT WAS CREATED TO
HELP FAMILIES AND CAL WORKS
PROGRAMS TO MEET THE COST OF
PERMANENT HOUSING. OR PROVIDE
EMERGENCY SHELTER WHEN A FAMILY
IS EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OR
IS AT RISK OF IT THE PROGRAM
PROVIDE TEMPORARY I'M HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE FOR FAMILIES TO
SECURE HOUSING FOR UP TO SIXTEEN
CALENDAR DAYS IN A TWELVE MONTH
PERIOD. THE PROGRAM ALSO HELP
FAMILIES SECURE PERMANENT
HOUSING BY PAYING FOR A DEPOSIT.
AND LAST MONTH'S RENT. THE
PROBLEM IS THAT THIS ASSISTANCE
COMES IN SMALL AMOUNTS AND WITH
MANY MANY HURDLES IN FRONT. HOW
IT WORKS TEMPORARY IS TEMPORARY
ASSISTANCE- IS ISSUED FOR THREE
DAYS THEN FAMILIES CAN COME BACK
FOR ANOTHER SEVEN DAYS THEN THEY
CAN COME BACK A THIRD TIME. FOR
SIX DAYS OF HELP. THIS IS A
TOTAL OF SIXTEEN DAYS OF
ASSISTANCE. PUT YOURSELF IN
THESE INDIVIDUAL SHOES LET ME
TELL YOU A LITTLE STORY I LIKE
TELLING STORIES OF PEOPLE WHO
I'VE ENCOUNTERED IN MY DISTRICT
HER NAME IS TONYA. TONYA HAS
CHILDREN TONYA AND HER CHILDREN
HAVE ARE HOMELESS AND NEED HELP
AND THEY NEED HELP NOW. THEY
HAVE A LITTLE TO NO MONEY IN
THEIR POCKETS HAVE NO CAR BUT
THEY FIND A WAY TO THE COUNTY
WELFARE DEPARTMENT AND WAIT FOR
HOURS HOURS TO SPEAK. THEY'RE
APPROVED FOR THREE DAYS FOR
TEMPORARY HOUSING ASSISTANCE
THREE DAYS. THEY UP THAT THIS
ASSISTANCE RUN OUT NOW THEY HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THIS PROCESS TWO
MORE TIMES TO GET THE FOR
SIXTEEN DAYS A TEMPORARY
ASSISTANCE. FOR TONYA AND HER
FAMILY. THIS IS MORE BARRIERS
THIS IS NOT JUST A BARRIER BUT
IF THE BOULDER. THAT IS BLOCKING
THE WAY FOR THEIR HOUSING. IT IS
A BARRIER THAT MEANS THAT HEARD
HER CHILDREN WILL HAVE TO SLEEP
OUTSIDE IN THE RAIN GRABBED
THEIR BELONGINGS TO GET. UP AND
MOVE AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN.
KEEPING BUYING FOOD BECAUSE THEY
NEED TO FIGHT A WAY BACK TO THE
WELFARE OFFICE TO RECEIVE THE
ASSISTANCE THAT THEY DEL SO
DESPERATELY NEEDS. MEMBERS AGAIN
I ASK YOU TO PUT YOURSELF IN HER
SHOES BUT JUST ONE DAY JUST TO
IMAGINE. ON TAKING ALL YOUR
BELONGINGS AND TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO GET TO THE WELFARE
OFFICE TO GET OTHER DIGITAL
RECHARGE TO FIND ASSISTANCE AND
GET SHELTER BURNER FAMILIES IN
OUR STATE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA 1-005-100-0200 AND
SEVENTY EIGHT CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. ARE ON THE STREETS
WITHOUT SHELTER AS WE SPEAK HERE
RIGHT NOW TODAY CALIFORNIA HAS
THE LARGEST HOMELESS POPULATION
IN THE NATION. CALIFORNIA IS THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD UNDERSCORE IN THE WORLD
BUT WE HAVE ONE THIRD OF THE
TOTAL HOMELESS POPULATION IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. AND ON
AND HALF OF THEM ARE RIGHT IN MY
BACKYARD IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
THESE ARE NOT JUST NUMBERS. WE
ALL HAVE A TONYA IN OUR
DISTRICTS SOMEWHERE. WE NEED
STRONG SOLUTIONS TO THIS GROWING
PROBLEM AB TWENTY TO THIRTY
WOULD REQUIRE THAT THE ENTIRE
SIXTEEN DAYS OFFERED BY CAO
WORKS HOMELESS ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM IS WILL BE ISSUED IN
TOTAL DURING ONE VISIT A FAMILY
SEEKING IMMEDIATE ASSISTANCE
ADDITIONALLY. THIS BILL WOULD
ELIMINATE THE ONE YEAR RULE FOR
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE AT
AUTHORIZED CAO WORKS- HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE FOR- ANY INCIDENCE OF
HOMELESSNESS IN TWO THOUSAND AND
A TWENTIETH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE THE PROGRAM APPROVED
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE FOR
PROXIMITY. THIRTY THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE
FAMILIES. THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
FOR EVEN MORE FAMILIES TO BE
SERVED WITH THE RESOURCES THAT
NEEDS TO GET TO THEM AND GET TO
THEM NOW SO THEY CAN GET OFF OF
OUR STREETS WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL WILL BE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA WELFARE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION. AND A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WHO IS
SELF INTRODUCE. GO AHEAD. UGH
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRISTOPHER SUNSETS
POLICY ADVOCATE THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WE'RE
PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR OF THE
OF THIS MEASURE AND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TO THIRTY.
AS MENTIONED BY THE AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL REMOVES BARRIERS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY IN PLACE FOR
FAMILIES ARE CAL WORKS
RECIPIENTS AND IN NEED OF
HOUSING ASSISTANCE MANY OF THEM
WERE ALREADY STRUGGLING TO MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS WE KNOW WE
KNOW TODAY MANY FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA ON THE VERGE OF BEING
ON HOUSE. MANY OF THEM ARE STILL
RECOVERING FROM THE PAST TIME IT
CAN CONTINUE TO FACE
DISPLACEMENT AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY ONE SIR THAT COVERS
ALMOST ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IS
ADJUSTED TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE RECIPIENTS SEEKING EVEN%
GREATER ASSISTANCE IN THE MOST
CIRCUMSTANCES ST MADAM. CHAN
REAR DRIVER. THANK YOU AND
MISTER- WE CAN HEAR FROM YOUR-
TWISTED. WITNESSES I KEVIN S.
ONE IN. IS HE PERSON OR ON THE
PHONE HE I WAS INFORMED IS
CURRENTLY RUNNING LATE- OKAY- SO
WE CAN JUST FOREGO THAT AND TAKE
OF HIS TESTIMONY AS THE-
TESTIMONY MOVING FOR TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU- OKAY I'M GONNA HAVE TO ANY-
WITNESSES SUPPORT. THAT THAT MAY
BE IN THE ROOM. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES AND- OKAY SEEN NONE-
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINES FOR A WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO TWO THREE
ZERO. THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO AGAIN
THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY TO
THIRTY. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD- JERRY CALL WITH
NOURISH CALIFORNIA INSTRUCTABLE
THANK. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU OPERATOR-
NOW WILL AT HEAR FROM ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM. DO WE HAVE ANYBODY THAT
WANTS TO OPPOSE THIS BILL IN THE
ROOM. OKAY SEEN NINE OPERATOR DO
YOU HAVE ANYBODY IN THE QUEUE-
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWO TWO THREE ZERO. GIVE YOUR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY TO
THIRTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO IN OPPOSITION. OF AB.
TWO TWO THREE ZERO. AND WE DO
HAVE TO IN Q. ONE MOMENT MADAM
CHAIR WERE GIVEN THEIR LINE
NUMBERS. K. AND AS A REMINDER WE
ARE ON A B. TWENTY TO THIRTY IN
OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF THIRTEEN SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS KAREEM POTS AND AYE
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT QUESTION WILL COME OUR
NEXT. ONE WILL COME FROM
THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE. AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER OPPOSITION THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU
OPERATOR- SO BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE TO HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR MANY MEMBERS FOR
SOME OF AMBER GIPSON. AT THE
HEAD ASSEMBLYMEMBER. THE
COMMENTS I JUST WANT TO THANK A
- ASSEMBLY MEMBER- AND I. AS A
FORMER CAL WORKS DIRECTOR I MEAN
YOUR TOUCH ON HOMELESS BUT HE
WHICH WHICH ALSO TOUCHING ON IS
THAT WE HAVE A SHORTAGE OF CASE
WORKERS IN THERE THEY ARE SO
STRESSED OUT RIGHT BECAUSE OF
CASELOADS OVER AND OVER YOU'RE
MAKING THEIR JOB A LOT EASIER
NOT JUST EASIER BUT THE TIME.
FOR THEM TO GO. DO OTHER UP
FIGURE OUT HOW TO HELP THEM OUT
EVEN FURTHER YEAH RIGHT THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE DOING TO. SO I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR- FOR
THIS BILL- IT GOES A LONG WAY
NOT JUST IN YOUR DISTRICT BUT IT
GOES A LONG WAY MY DISTRICT TO.
INSIDE LOVE DAD MY NAME AS A CO
AUTHOR TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DULY NOTED THANK YOU THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT- LIKE TO CLOSE. ADAM
SCHENK AND COMMITTEE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY. ALSO WANT TO TAKE A
POINT OF SPECIAL PROVISIONS
THANK TONYA. TONYA FOR BEING
COURAGEOUS ENOUGH TO WANT PUSHED
FAST PUSH PAST. HER
EMBARRASSMENT. PUSH PASS- THE
pTHERE'S NO ONE THAT CARES. BUT
BEING ABLE TO BE VERY BOLD.
ENOUGH TO SHARE HER STORY WITH
US AND SHE IS A HERO. I AND
SPEAKS SO- SPEAKS SO MUCH AND
SOLD OT FOR OTHER PEOPLE. WHO
ARE AFRAID OR FOR WHATEVER
REASON CANNOT SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES I WANT TO SAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TANYA TANYA HELP
IS ON THE WAY. WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE
TO HELP FAMILIES. WHO ARE DOWN
ON THEIR LUCK. WHO ARE HOMELESS
AND EXPERIENCING THE WORST TIMES
OF THEIR ENTIRE LIVES. IF YOU
CAN JUST IMAGINE PUT YOURSELF IN
A PLACE WHERE. YOU DON'T KNOW
WHERE YOU CAN LAY YOUR HEAD AT
NIGHT THESE ARE PEOPLE'S
REALITIES EACH AND EVERY DAY.
AND I'M HAPPY. YOU KNOW FOR ONE
WHO- SPEND THE NIGHT WITH
HOMELESS PEOPLE AND I HAVE BEEN
DOING THIS SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN UP IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. I UNDERSTAND BECAUSE A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHO I'VE
ENCOUNTERED BY SPENDING THE
NIGHT WITH HOMELESS PEOPLE DON'T
WANT TO BE HOMELESS. THEY WANT A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD THEY WANT
TO BE ABLE TO. SLEEP IN A WARM
BED AND HAVE COVERS AND FOOD IN
THE REFRIGERATOR. BUT THAT IS
NOT THE REALITY OF PEOPLE
HURTING HERE IN THIS STATE THE
FIFTH WORLD ECONOMY. AND TODAY I
WANT TO BE ABLE TO TELL TANYA
HELP IS ON THE WAY. IN WHICH OUR
AYE VOTE HELP WILL BE ON THE
WAY. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK. BUT
I VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU SOME
OF EVERY SENATE AS WE HAVE- THE
WORLD. BUT ON. THANK YOU. OKAY
SEE. ASSEMBLY WOMAN CARILLO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO- PRESENT AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY FIVE.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT TO SOME BILL TWENTY SIX
SIXTY FIVE THROUGH A BLIND
REMOVAL PRACTICE PILOT THIS BILL
AIMS TO ADDRESS THE OVER
REPRESENTATION. OF BLACK AND
BROWN YOUTH IN OUR STATE'S CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. IMPLICIT BIAS IS
A UNIVERSAL PHENOMENON NOT
LIMITED BY RACE GENDER OR CLASS
THE US HAS LONG STRUGGLED WITH
RACE AND IMPLICIT BIAS WITHIN IT
SYSTEMS AND STRUCTURES. AND
THERE IS AMPLE EVIDENCE TO SHOW
HOW INDIVIDUAL IMPLICIT BIAS
LEADS TO DECISION MAKING THAT
GOES AGAINST CONSCIOUS VALUES
AND IDEALS ACCORDING TO THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVICES 7%
OF CHILDREN IN L. A. COUNTY ARE
BLACK. YET BETWEEN APRIL
TWENTIETH APRIL TWENTY TWENTIETH
IN MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE L. A. COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVICES
REPORTED 24% OF CHILDREN REMOVED
FROM THEIR HOMES WERE ACTUALLY
BLACK EVEN THOUGH THEY CONSIST
OF ONLY 7% OF THE POPULATION.
FOR CONTRAST 20% OF CHILDREN IN
L. A. COUNTY OR WHITEN REPRESENT
ONLY 12% OF THOSE REMOVED FROM
THEIR HOMES DURING THAT SAME
TIME PERIOD. TO ADDRESS THIS
DISPARITY L. A. COUNTY IS IN THE
PROCESS OF IMPLEMENTING THEIR
OWN PILOT PROJECT AND PROGRAM TO
DOCUMENT THE RESULTS OF THEIR
DECISION MAKING STRATEGY. AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY FIVE WILL
ENSURE THAT FAMILIES INCLUDED IN
THE PILOT WILL RECEIVE A FAIR
HEARING AND NOT A- MY OF.
SEPARATE DUE TO THAT EMPLOY BIAS
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ARE
JESSICA CHALLONER SOCIAL WORKER
AND CEO OF CHANDLER. HEALING
SERVICES AND ARE SHOWN A
BENJAMIN WITH PARENTS- PARENTING
FOR LIBERATION. THANK YOU FROM
THE WOMAN- OPERATORCAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR THE
FIRST THE FIRST WITNESS IN
SUPPORT- JESSICA CHANDLER. AND
MARK. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JEFF THE CHAPITRE AND I'M A
SOCIAL WORKER FOR L. A. COUNTY
DEPARTMENT SO YOUR FAMILY THIRTY
EIGHT. I'M ACTIVATED ACOSTA CARE
AT EIGHT EIGHTEEN AFTER
SURVIVING PARENTS WERE MONSTERS
EXTREME POVERTY CAN CHANGE HIM
PREGNANCY HOMELESSNESS AND PTSD
HI MARK WATER STREET. I WOULD
NEVER GO TO WORK AT A THIRD I
CAME WITH THE VEHICLE A MASTER'S
DEGREE WITH EMPHASIS IN URBAN
CHILD WELFARE HERE'S A
SPECIALIZED TRAINING ACTIVITY
AND A WHOLE PART ACTUALLY WILL
BE BACK YOU'RE THE MOST ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED NEXT TO OUR
FAMILY. I SHOWED UP EARLY STAYED
LATE ALWAYS NOT THE EXTRA MILE
OFFICE MY OWN MONEY TO SHOW FOR
MY CLIENT'S BIRTHDAYS OR MAKE
THE NECESSARY MAINTAIN A FAMILY
TOGETHER I DO NOT PERSONAL
CONNECTION A- THE BILL'S CHANCES
PORTSMOUTH. I THINK THE TIME
TOGETHER AND VALIDATE WORK
ELEVEN AM. I DON'T HAVE ANYONE
TO. LOOK OUT FOR NEWLY FOUND
PRODUCT. I CAN I. WHY WE CAN GET
HOLDEN. UP BY THEIR BOOT LIKE.
BUT EVEN SO BACK AT. FIVE PART
THEIR CHILDREN. OUT OF THE
SPECIAL PERFECT. WHAT FAMILY
BECAUSE I FELT. WE SHOULD GET
THE FOR. OF ANY GENERATE CYCLE.
IMPACT NOT COMMUNITY. THE
THOUGHT WHO WORK ON THE FRONT
LINES START BURN OUT. NOT SUDDEN
THE VIEW AMERICA BY WHICH THE
PHYSICAL ABUSE CASES ARE TO ALL.
STATE BEFORE YOU WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE CHECK YOUR-
MULTIPLE TIMES A DAY.
THE TICKET AT THE MEDIA. WE ALL
FEAR BLACK. INCLUDING MEET. OUR
GREAT THAT BLACK EQUAL DANGER.
WHAT KIND OF GOT THE CHECK MY
INSECURITY BUT I DO BECAUSE I
HAVE THE I BELIEVE THAT THEY
HAVE IMMENSE POTENTIAL TO CREATE
A FUTURE FOR THEMSELVES BUT THEY
CAN BE HAPPY AND- YES THEY ARE
DEPORTED TO PROVIDE EQUITY AND
SERVICE. IS NEEDED TO OVERCOME
HISTORICAL TRAUMA THEY'RE BORN
INTO. THEIR REGULAR THIRTY THAT
EVERY LEVEL SERVICE IN
CALIFORNIA CHAO WILL PROTECT
THEM FROM THE TICKET TO
REUNIFICATION ACKERMAN. WE
CANNOT AND DO ALL THE YEARS
AFFECT THE RATE THAT HAS HAD ON
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. BUT
THE DATA SHOWS THERE'S A-
PROBLEM. HI WE ADDRESS. PLEASE
YEAH AB. TWO SIX SIX FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OPERATE CAN YOU-
OPEN LINE FOR THE NEXT WITNESS.
WERE SHOWN OF ENGINE. AFTER
THANK YOU CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ROSHAN THE BENJAMIN AND
I AM A PARENT ADVISORY BOARD
MEMBER WITH PERRIN AND TO
LIBERATION ONE OF THE SPONSORS
THAT A. B. TWO SIX SIX FIVE AS A
CHILD MY BIRTH MOTHER STRUGGLED
WITH DRUG ADDICTION BUT RATHER
THAT PROVIDE HER REHAB SHE WAS
INCARCERATED AND I WAS SEPARATED
FROM HER. ACTUALLY MY FATHER AND
HIS WIFE WERE ABLE TO TAKE ME IN
AND SAVE ME FROM THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. I WAS TWENTY
THREE YEARS AGO WHEN MY BIRTH
MOTHER HAD MY BABY SISTER. BUT
SHE STILL STRUGGLED WITH
ADDICTION FIVE STOP FOR MY
SISTER TO STAY WITH THE FAMILY.
BUT I WASN'T GIVEN ANY SUPPORT
TO KEEP MY SISTER INSTEAD I WAS
JUDGE FOR MY OWN CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCE. IN THE CHILD WELFARE
. USE MY MOTHER'S ADDICTION
AGAINST ME THEY ALSO JUDGE ME
BECAUSE I WAS A YOUNG BLACK
SINGLE MOTHER. YEAH MY SISTER
WAS PLACED WITH A FOSTER FAMILY.
I WAS TOLD BY THE SOCIAL WORKER
THAT THEIR HOUSE WAS MORE
ACCEPTABLE AND STABLE AND MINE
DOESN'T BECAUSE I WAS A BLACK
SINGLE MOTHER LIVING IN LOW
INCOME HOUSING. K. MY RACE AGE
MARITAL STATUS AND INCOME WAS.
USED TO TAKE MY SISTER WAY. AND
I AM NOT UNIQUE THAT CHILDREN
ARE 22% OF THE CALIFORNIA FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM WHILE MAKING UP ONLY
7% OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
POPULATION OVERALL. THE U. S.
HAS LEARNED STRUGGLE WIT REYES
AND IMPLICIT BIAS WITHIN IT
SYSTEMS AND STRUCTURES. AND
BETTER AMPLE EVIDENCE TO SHOW
HOW INDIVIDUAL INTERESTED BUYERS
WHO LEADS TO DECISION MAKING
THAT TEARS APART BY BLACK
FAMILIES. LET'S NOT STOP AND THE
TIME IS NOW. SB. TWO SIX SIX
FIVE. THIS IS A CRITICAL STEP TO
STOP INTERESTED BY. AND SHALL WE
TO KEEP COUNT OF FOUND TO. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- NEVER
GONNA OPEN IT UP TO ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OKAY SAY NINE OPERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SIX SIX FIVE. YOU'RE FREE IN
SUPPORT OF AB AT TWO SIX SIX
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU ARE SUPPORT OF AB.
TWO EIGHT SIX SIX FIVE. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE THE TWELVE OF
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JORDAN THE- LEGISLATIVE MANAGER
OF CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION
OR SEQUENCE THE WE ARE A
STATEWIDE MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION COMPRISED THE
CURRENT OR FORMER FAUCI'S
DEDICATED TO TRANSFORM THE
SYSTEM THIRD LEGISLATIVE POLICY
AND PRACTICE CHANGE. THE BILL TO
ADVOCATE FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY THE CHILD
WELFARE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
WITHOUT A RACIAL EQUITY LINE
THIS IS WHY OUR MEMBERS ARE
SUPPORT OF AB. TWO SIX SIX FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I THINK
THE NEXT IT WILL GO TO TWELVE A
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS SHAVER SAID I'M A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER WITH
PARENTING FOR LIBERATION AND
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SIX
SIX FIVE AND RESPECTFULLY URGING
I ABOUT. POLITICIAN TO THE
FOLLOWING. THANK IN ADDITION TO
THE FOLLOWING PEOPLE AND
ORGANIZATIONS TO FIND ON A BEACH
IN. GENET HOW. WITH FOR DAWKINS
BUT ANASTASIA BOB THE NICHOLS.
THAT'S QUITE THE TICKET CARE.
YOU NEED A DOCTOR. JOSHUA COULD
OPEN. JOHN AND THEIR RAMOS SORRY
THIRTIETH BEAGLE EARL BENJAMIN
REGINA BENJAMIN AT THE GARAGE
JURIES. GREEN SCHERING MORE ON
THE TYLER CYNTHIA ALVAREZ THE
TREATING THE LINE. MONICA GONNA
RACHEL ROSE. CAN YOU CHECK CAN
RESET HERE THEN THE QUESTION
GREEN COPPER. THE NATION'S
SIMPSON AND YOU'RE ON THE AIR.
THE LARGE SCREEN. THE MINIMUM
MALAKAND VERY AND YOUR MAN ARIEL
BENJAMIN. THANK YOU LANDSTRASSE
FINISH A PAINTING. AND THEN WHAT
. THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK IN
OCTOBER SO I WAS TWELVE OF
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARE
YOU GOING BROWN WITH HERITAGE
COLLABORATION AGAIN LOG THE
VOTE. ON THIS IMPORTANT POLICY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTEEN
OH SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S REGINA MOORE
I URGE YOUR STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION AND I WANT TO
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN Q. AT
THE TIME AN OBJECT THANK YOU
OPERATOR- NEXT WE GO TO ANY OP
PRIMARY OPPOSITION- IN THE ROOM
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY THAT LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWO
SIX SIX FIVE. IN THE ROOM. OKAY
SEEN NONE. OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE IN THE QUEUE
TO- TESTIFIED OPPOSITION FOR
HIS. AGAINST AB TWO SIX SIX FIVE
. YOU'RE FREE IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWO EIGHT SIX SIX FIVE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN
THEY'LL FOR ANYOPPOSITION OF AB. TWO SIX SIX FIVE. M. MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. OKAY THANK
YOU OPERATOR- NEXT WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
. OKAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. A KILL AND AS SOON AS
WE HAVE A QUORUM WE WILL TAKE A
VOTE ON YOUR BILL THANK YOU.
OKAY NEXT THAT WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN SURVIVED HIS- FOR
PRESENTING ON AB TWO FOUR SIX
SIX.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ON ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY SIX.
COLLEAGUES I BET PART BROKE IN
STATES LIKE TEXAS AND FLORIDA
ATTACK AND STIGMATIZE OUR LGBTQ
COMMUNITY FOR DOING NOTHING MORE
THAN ASSERTING OUR RIGHT TO
EXIST ENJOY THIS. IS EVERYONE
ELSE IF WE FAIL TO PUSH BACK ON
OFFENSIVE RHETORIC THAT UNFAIRLY
CASTS THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY AS
BEING ANTI FAMILY R. G. B. T. Q.
INDIVIDUALS WILL CONTINUE TO
FACE DISCRIMINATION FOR DOING
NOTHING MORE THAN EXERCISING
THEIR EQUAL RIGHTS TO BUILD A
FAMILY OF THEIR OWN. THE PURPOSE
OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY SIX IS TO TAKE THIS
HATEFUL RHETORIC HAD ON. IT DOES
SO BY REMOVING BARRIERS TO LGBTQ
FAMILIES WISHING TO SERVE AS
RESOURCE FAMILIES FOR FOSTER
CHILDREN AND TO REMOVE THE
STATUTORY STIGMA ATTACHED TO
LGBTQ FOSTER CHILDREN. THANKS TO
SIGNIFICANT REFORM APPROVED BY
THE LEGISLATURE IN RECENT YEARS
MORE AND MORE LGBTQ FAMILIES ARE
SEEKING TO OFFER THEIR SERVICES
AS RESOURCE FAMILIES WHICH
PROVIDES OUT OF HOME CARE FOR
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE.
ASSEMBLY C. AGENCIES ARE BEING
SUPPORTIVE PROTECTING PRACTICES
FOR LGBTQ COMMUNITY AND
RECRUITING RECRUITING
PERSPECTIVE LGBT Q. FAMILY
RESOURCES. OTHER STILL EMPLOYEE
RULES AND POLICIES THAT
PERPETUATE UNFAIR AND OUTDATED
STEREOTYPES ABOUT WHO SHOULD AND
SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO TAKE IN
TWO FOSTER CHILDREN. IN
PARTICULAR SOCIAL WORKERS IN
CHILD WELFARE WELFARE AGENCIES
ARE EMPOWERED TO EXERCISE
SIGNIFICANT DISCRETION HELPING
DECIDE WHO GETS LICENSED AS A
RESOURCE FAMILY AND WHO DOES NOT
WITHOUT STATE PROTECTION AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION SOME SOCIAL
WORKERS MAY ALLOW THEIR PERSONAL
BIASES AGAINST THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY COMMUNITY TO CREATE
INSURMOUNTABLE BARRIERS FOR
OTHERWISE QUALIFIED. R. G. B. T.
Q. FAMILIES SEEKING TO SERVE AS
LEVINE RESOURCE FAMILIES
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
SIX WILL PROVIDE THESE NEEDED
PROTECTIONS BY PROHIBITING
PLACING AGENCIES FROM DECLINING
TO PLACE A FOSTER CHILD WITH THE
RESOURCE FAMILY SOLELY ON THE
GROUNDS THAT THE RESOURCE FAMILY
IDENTIFIES AS LGBTQ. ANOTHER
INCONVENIENT TRUTH IS THAT THE
L. G. B. YOUTH ARE OVER
REPRESENTED IN OUR FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM AND THE TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCE OF LGBTQ FOSTER
CHILDREN ARE TO ARE OFTEN
OVERLOOKED. DESPITE ONE WHAT ONE
MIGHT HEAR ON CERTAIN CABLE NEWS
CHANNELS R. G. B. T. Q. CHILDREN
OUR CHILDREN TO THEY ARE JUST AS
DESERVING OF RIGHTS LOVE AND
PROTECTION AS EVERYONE ELSE
UNFORTUNATELY MANY LGBTQ YOUTH
CONTINUE TO REPORT
DISCRIMINATION MARGINALIZATION
AND AN OVERALL LACK OF
ACCEPTANCE WHEN NAVIGATING OUR
STATE'S WELFARE SYSTEM THIS LACK
OF ACCEPTANCE IS MANIFESTED BY
THE FACT THAT MANY PLACING
AGENCIES INCLUDE LGBTQ FOSTER
CHILDREN IN THE LEGAL CATEGORY
OF HARD TO PLACE CHILDREN. THIS
WHOLLY UNFAIR CLASSIFICATION ON
THE BASIS OF SEXUAL ORIENTATION
ALONG CAN HINDER FOSTER
PLACEMENT AND UNNECESSARILY
INFLICT TRAUMA ON LGBTQ FOSTER
CHILDREN. AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
SIX FOUR AND THE STATUTORY
STIGMA BY REMOVING THE TERM HARD
TO PLACE CHILDREN FROM OUR STATE
LAWS WE MUST STRIVE TO INSTILL
THIS BASIC PRINCIPLE AND OUR
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM NO CHILD IS
TOO DIFFICULT TO LOVE. TO CARE.
FOR JUST BECAUSE THEIR RACE
RELIGION DSABILITY OR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION. MEMBERS UNTIL WE
SEE CONGRESS PASS NEW NATION
WIDE LAWS PROHIBITING
DISCRIMINATION ON THE BASIS OF
SEXUAL ORIENTATION GENDER
IDENTITY STATES LIKE CALIFORNIA
MUST STEP UP TO PROTECT EMBRACE
AND EMPOWER OUR LGBTQ COMMUNITY.
THEREFORE COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE STAND
FOR EQUAL RIGHTS FOR LGBTQ
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM NOW THAT'S FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
WOMAN- IF YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES
- IN OKAY. ALL RIGHT- SO WE'RE
GONNA DO IS WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THE HEARING ROOM AND SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OKAY YES. PAUL VASQUEZ WITH THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. KEVIN AS A CHORISTER
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OKAY
OPERATOR CAN YOU GO TO THE PHONE
LINES AND SEE IF WE HAVE ANYBODY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO FOUR SIX
SIX. THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO FOUR SIX SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
. AGAIN THAT IS THE ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO FOUR SIX SIX. WE WILL GO
TO LINE THIRTEEN NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI ARE YOU
DOING- MY NAME IS- VICTOR
SHANNON AND I AM CALLING IN A-
TO OPPOSE AB TWO TO. THREE OKAY
IT'S WRONG BILL THANK YOU SIR.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR ON GOING TO
GO AHEAD. OKAY I CAN REPEAT IT
WE ARE ON A. B. TWO FOUR SIX SIX
AN OP- IN SUPPORT- REVITALIZED
FORTINO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS LAURIE MCKAY CALLING
ON BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. EXADATA LINE TWELVE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS JANE CAN- WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS TIME OKAY-
BEFORE GOOD OPPOSITION- WE ARE
GONNA I THINK WE HAVE A QUORUM
SO. CALDERON. DAVIES ARAMBULA
BONTA BRIAN STONE THE PADUCAH.
WALDRON OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM
GREAT. OKAY OPERATOR CAN WE
PLEASE- ARE ACTUALLY DO WE HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION TO A. B- TWO TWO
FOUR SIX TWO FOUR SIX SIX IN THE
ROOM. OKAY SEEN NINE OPERATOR
COULD YOU OPEN THE LINES TO SEE
IF WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION. AB
THREE WERE USED IN OPPOSITION OF
AB. TWO FOUR SIX SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
ANY OPPOSITION. OF AB. TWO FOUR
SIX SIX. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
OF A ONE I MEAN THIS GIVE ME A
LEVIN SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS ALBERT AND I APPROACHED
EIGHTY TWO FOUR SIX SIX. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE WILL
GO TO LINE THIRTEEN FIFTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE DALLAS GOMEZ AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE NEXT TO GO TO AT
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M LOU
FROM MY DAD AND I HOPE FOR THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
LACTOBACILLI IN THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- MY NAME IS JOE
CRANIA AND I OPPOSE- THIS BILL
TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLD DISTRICT
THANKS HERE. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE TWELVE EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
CHRISTY MERIDIAN I OPPOSE AB TWO
FOUR SIX SIX THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE THIRTEEN THIRTY
FIVE. MY NAME IS MARIA MARTINEZ
AND I OPPOSE BUILT FOR SIX SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NETWORK
ONLINE THIRTEEN NINETY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIRTEEN NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU OPERATOR I'VE NOW
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS TO HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING FORWARD
THIS LEGISLATION AND JUST GOES
TO SHOW HOW. FAR WE STILL NEED
TO GO N THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TO RIGHT SIZE OUR OUR
LEGISLATION SO THAT REACHES TO
EVERY CORNER AN ASPECT OF. OUR
LIVES. THANK YOU. I'LL MAKE A
MOTION. OKAY ALL RIGHT GREAT.
OKAY GO AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL
. L. I. TARGET I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE THIS A MOMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE I'VE ON
THE BOW ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. THANK YOU
THE MOTION IS TO PASS CALDERON
ALL RIGHT WALDRON HI DAVIES.
DAVIES I ARAMBULA BONTA HI BONTA
HI BRIAN BRIAN IS STONE STONE I
THE ABUJA THE ABUJA I WALDRON.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN PICKING UP HERE. OKAY
ASSEMBLY WOMAN FRIEDMAN ARE YOU
READY TO PRESENT ON AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY NINE. YES I AM THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY NINE SUPPORT
THE SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION TO
ADULTHOOD OF YOUNG PEOPLE BY
ENSURING THAT FOSTER YOUTH
RETAIN ACCESS TO BENEFITS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR HOUSING
STATUS. ALLOWING THE COURTS TO
EXTEND ENROLLMENT AND EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE BEYOND AGE TWENTY
ONE UNTIL THE COUNTY HAS
FULFILLED ITS OBLIGATION TO
ENSURE THAT THE YOUTH HOW THE
NECESSARY SUPPORTS. AND SERVICES
REQUIRED UNDER. FOR TRANSITION
AGE FOSTER YOUTH THE LAW
EXPLICITLY REQUIRES THAT COUNTY
WELFARE AGENCIES PROVIDE
PROTECTIONS TO TRY TO ENSURE
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE LEAVE FOSTER
CARE WITH A CONCRETE PLAN FOR
THEIR DISCHARGE TO PROVIDE
SAFETY AND STABILITY AND
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR EXAMPLE STATE-LAW REQUIRES COUNTY CHILD
WELFARE AGENCIES AT THAT THE- AT
THE LAST GOOD REVIEW HEARING
BEFORE DEPENDENT CHILD TURNS
EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD AND EVERY
REVIEW HEARING THERE AFTER TO
SUBMIT A REPORT VERIFYING THAT
CERTAIN DOCUMENTS INFORMATION
AND SERVICES HAVE BEEN PROVIDED
TO THE MINOR OR THE NON MINOR
DEPENDING ON THE AGE. INCLUDING
THEIR SOCIAL SECURITY CARD BIRTH
CERTIFICATE AND A VALID ID AS
WELL AS ASSISTANCE WITH APPLYING
TO COLLEGE OR A CAREER TECHNICAL
PROGRAM AND SECURING HOUSING.
HOWEVER THE LAW IS UNCLEAR
REGARDING WHETHER COURT CAN
MAINTAIN JURISDICTION OVER THE
YOU WANT TO TURN ANYONE WHAT
COUNTY CHILD WELFARE AGENCY HAS
NOT MET REQUIREMENTS SO THE
COUNTY HASN'T PROVIDED THOSE
SERVICES. ONE COUNT COUNTY
FAILED TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO
SECURE HOUSING. YOUTH IN THE
EXCITED A FOSTER CARE SYSTEM OUR
OFFICE. POSTED ON THE STREETS
PERSON OUR PRISONS AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY NINE WILL ENSURE THAT
THOSE FOSTER YOUTH RETAIN ACCESS
TO SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
REGARDLESS OF THEIR HOUSING
STATUS AND ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY
WITH CURRENT LAW. BY INSURING
THAT FOSTER YOUTH INCLUDING
EXPECTED IN PARENTING YOUTH
RECEIVE CRITICAL BENEFITS LIKE A
CLOTHING ALLOWANCE AN INFANT
SUPPLEMENTS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
PLACEMENTS. CLARIFYING THAT THE
COURT MAY KEEP IT HERE- A CASE
OPEN PAST AGE TWENTY ONE IF THE
REQUIREMENTS TO TERMINATE
JURISDICTION OF NOT BEEN
SATISFACTORILY MET. AND
REQUIRING THE COUNTY WELFARE
DEPARTMENT TO MAKE INTENSIVE AND
ONGOING EFFORTS TO ENSURE THAT
YOU HAVE HOUSING STABILITY
BEFORE THEY EXIT THE SYSTEM.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE FIRST
DATES THAT STARTED IT AND
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE PROGRAM AND
OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST
TWELVE YEARS WE'VE HEARD FROM
FOSTER YOUTH AND PROVIDERS. THE
BOUT THEIR SUCCESSES BUT ALSO
ABOUT THE SHORTCOMINGS OF THE
PROGRAM AND AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
NINE IS TRYING TO HELP REMEDY
SOME OF THE SHORTCOMINGS THAT
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY WILL BE DEBT IN
POLK WHO IS A CLIENT A PUBLIC
COUNSEL AND KRISTEN POWER.
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN. AFTERNOON
TEMPERATURES ARE WHAT THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS.
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY NINE.
AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN IS CO SPONSORED BY THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
CHILDREN FAULKNER CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC HEALTH TWENTY FIVE
CENTER. TO ENSURE THAT YOU CAN
FOSTER CARE RETAIN ACCESS TO
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS REGARDLESS
OF THE HOUSING STATUS. AND
ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY CURRENT
LAW SUCCESSFUL DISCHARGE
PLANNING OBLIGATIONS. BY
ENSURING THAT FOSTER YOUTH
INCLUDING EXPECTANT PARENTING
YOU RECEIVE CRITICAL BENEFITS
LIKE THE CLOTHING ALLOWANCE. AN
EMPATH SUPPLEMENT REGARDLESS OF
THEIR PLACEMENT STATUS.
CLARIFYING THAT THE COURT MAY
KEEP A CASE OPEN PAST AGE TWENTY
ONE IF THE REQUIREMENTS TO
TERMINATE JURISDICTION NOT BEEN
SATISFACTORILY MET. EREKLE OFFER
A PERMIT TO MAKE AN- EFFORT TO
ENSURE YOU HAVE HOUSING
STABILITY. BEFORE. THEY EXIT THE
SYSTEM. AND HOW RECENT CAL USE
ON THE EXTENT OF FONG CARE PER
HAS NUMERO BENEFITS FOR PRETTY.
YOUNG ADULTS INCLUDING
IMPROVEMENTS IN EDUCATION
EMPLOYABILITY HOUSING OFFICIAL
SUPPORT AS WELL AS REDUCTIONS IN
PREGNANCY AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEMS INVOLVEMENT. HOWEVER
THAT SAME STUDY REVEALED THAT
OVER 35% OF YOUTH REPORTED THEY
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS WHILE
ACTIVELY AND GET ROLLED AND
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE. AND ARE
ADVOCATES WHO WORK WITH OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE REPORT THAT THEIR
ONGOING STRUGGLES EVERY DAY FOR
YOUTH WHO ARE ENSURING.
INCREASING DIFFICULTIES IN
OBTAINING HOUSING STABILITY BOTH
WHILE AN EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
AND POST CARE. AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY NINE IS INTENDED TO
REMOVE THESE TWO MAJOR BARRIERS
THAT PREVENT YOU FROM FOSTER
CARE FROM FULLY BENEFITING FROM
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE. AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY NINE WOULD ADDRESS
THESE BARRIERS BY DECOUPLING THE
EXPECTANT PARENTING PAYMENT AND
CLOTHING ALLOWANCE. FROM THE
REQUIREMENT THAT YOU'VE BEEN
APPROVED PLACEMENT AND BY
ALLOWING THEM TO NOW COURTS
MAINTAIN JURISDICTION PASSED
TWENTY ONE. FOR THE PURPOSES OF
COMPLETING THE TRANSITION
PLANNING REQUIREMENTS THERE ARE
ENUMERATED AND STATE LAW. WE
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON
THESE CRITICAL ISSUES ENSURING
THAT ARE OLDER YOU HAVE ACCESS
TO AN COULD RECEIVE THE
NECESSARY SUPPORT AND SERVICES
THEY NEED. TO HELP THEM
SUCCESSFULLY ATTAINED
INDEPENDENCE. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE OF. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES. CAN DO WE HAVE ANY UP
I THINK WE HAVE A WITNESS ON THE
PHONE OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY OF
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM CHECK. THIS
IS ONE OF OUR PRIMARY. OKAY
BRIDGE SECOND WITNESSES ONLINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU.
CORRECT I CAN LOS REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
YOUTH IN SUPPORT. YOU HAVE
ANOTHER WHICH IS THE CORRECT OF
MY- WE'RE SUPPOSED TO HAVE
ANOTHER WITNESS ONLINE A DAY IN
AND POKE. OPERATOR. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LET ME SEE IF I SEE HIM
ONE MOMENT THANK YOU. NOT BE HIS
NAME- YOU MIGHT BE AND ONE OF
THE QUEUE IS UNDER OUR LINE
NUMBER. DO AND GIVEN A MEMBER WE
CAN SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM RIGHT NOW SO
I CAN COME BACK AND WE'LL GO
BACK TO THE LINE DOES THAT WORK.
SURE GREAT DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. OKAY THEN
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO THE
LINE WE CAN SEE IF WE CANNOT GET
HOLD OF THE SECOND ONE IS PLEASE
THANK YOU OPERATOR. OKAY MMHM.
WELL THIS MOVE TO LINE UP
FOURTEEN TEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE FOURTEEN TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ARE YOU A. B. FIFTY TWO
THREE. CAN THANK YOU WE'LL GO
NEXT TO LINE FOURTEEN TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON I LIVE IN
CANADA HALF OF FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA INTO COURT THANK YOU
. THANK YOU IN MEXICO TO LINE
TWELVE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE TWELVE FIFTY A LINE IS OPEN. IT WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ANGELA KELLY I WOULD LIKE TO
HELLO AB TWO THREE I AM
COMPLETELY AND- OKAY I THINK
WE'RE WE'RE TAKING SUPPORT RIGHT
NOW. THANK YOU TWELVE EIGHT
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON INSTRUCTOR HOW
PEOPLE WITH CHILDREN NOW IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
NINE. THANK YOU LINE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MARIA MEDINA WITH PUBLIC COUNCIL
OR FOR CALLING IN FOR CHILDREN
OFTEN TURN BOTH OUR
ORGANIZATIONS- IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY NINE.
THANK YOU ND TWELVE FIFTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DURING DINNER
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I DID NOT FIND THE
OTHER WITNESS IN THE QUEUE OKAY
WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE'LL MOVE ON
TO- ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES AND
IF THEY COULD COME BACK WILL
BOOK WILL HAVE. ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. SING NINE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. C. NINE
ANY OPPOSITION ONLINE OPERATOR.
THEY GIVE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO IN
OPPOSITION. MADAM CHAIR I HAVE
NO OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU UGH COMMITTEE
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. YES A
FAN OF THIS BILL FOR MANY MANY
REASONS- AND I KNOW IT'S A HEAVY
LIFT AND IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
CO AUTHORS I'M HAPPY TO JOIN YOU
IN THIS FIGHT. SO HONORED TO
HAVE YOU THANK. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. OR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE- GO HEAD. NOPE OKAY I
THINK WE'D LIKE TO CLOSE JUST- I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
AND THANKS FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
NEVER MOTION. THE TWENTY SECOND
SECT. WELCOME. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CALDERON DAVIES HI
DAVIES I ARAMBULA. BONTA AYE
BONTA AYE BRIAN BRIAN ICE JONES
STONE IV ABUJA THE ABUJA I
WALDRON. THANK YOU. LEAVE THE OF
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT UNDER
MEMBERS ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
BE MOVING ON TO AB TWO SIX TWO
EIGHT- ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I PRESENT TO YOU AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT WHICH
WILL REVISE A COMMERCIALLY
SEXUALLY EXPLOITED CHILDREN
PROGRAM KNOWN AS SEA SICK. TO
ENSURE BOTH SEX AND LABOR
TRAFFICKED CHILDREN IDENTIFIED
SUPPORTED AND PROTECTED. THE SIX
THAT PROGRAM WAS CREATED WITH
THE INTENT OF IDENTIFYING
PROVIDING SERVICES TO SEXUALLY
TRAFFICKED CHILDREN BY PROVIDING
COUNTIES WITH POPPED IN. TO THE
PROGRAM WITH FUNDING WHEN THEY
OPTED IN THEY WERE PROVIDED WITH
FUNDING AND RESOURCES WITH THIS
FUNDING AND RESOURCES COUNTIES
COULD ESTABLISH LOCAL TASK
FORCES TO DIRECTLY INTERVENE IN
CASES OF SEXUALLY TRAFFICKED
CHILDREN. AND PROVIDE SERVICES
WELL THIS IS THE PROGRAM HAS
WORKED TO PROVIDE SEXUALLY
TRAFFICKED CHILDREN WITH
ASSISTANCE RESOURCES LABOR
TRAFFICKED CHILDREN HAVE BEEN
MISIDENTIFIED AND DO NOT RECEIVE
THE SAME LEVEL OF TREATMENT OF
SEXUALLY TRAFFICKED CHILDREN.
THIS IS TROUBLING WHEN
CONSIDERING REESE MAKOLA TO
ABOLISH SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING
SUGGESTS THAT LABOUR TRAP KING
MAKES UP 39% OF ALL HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN CALIFORNIA. TO
COMBAT THIS ISSUE AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY EIGHT WILL. FIRST REVISED
TO SEE SAID PROGRAM TO INCLUDE
ALL CHILDREN WHO ARE VICTIMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING BOTH SEXUAL
AND LABOR TRAFFICKED. OTHERWISE
CHECK A CHILD A VICTIM OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING TO BE A JUDGE THEY
DEPENDED ON OF THE JUVENILE
COURT IN CASES FOR THE PARENT OR
GUARDIAN FAILS OR IS UNABLE TO
PROTECT THE CHILD FROM BEING
EXPLOITED. AND THIRD THE BILL
WOULD PROHIBIT A SOCIAL WORKER
FROM TAKING TEMPORARY CUSTODY OF
A CHILD VICTIM OF TRAFFICKING IF
THE PARENT OR GUARDIAN HAD NOT
PARTICIPATE DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY TO THE CHILD'S
TRAFFICKING. BY ENSURING THESE
MECHANISMS ARE IN PLACE AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT WILL
PROVIDE LABOR TRAFFICKED
CHILDREN WITH THE SAME COURT
PROCEDURES SERVICES AND
PROTECTIONS A SEXUALLY
TRAFFICKED CHILDREN HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS JOSEPH
WILL RELATE VIELE. FROM THE
SUNITA JANE ANTI TRAFFICKING
POLICY INITIATIVE OF LOYOLA LAW
SCHOOL AND ETHAN RARICK
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FROM THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION WHO
WILL BE TESTIFYING REMOTELY.
TIGERGRAPH GOOD AFTERNOON I
MEMBERS ARE MANY JOSEPH JELLO
POLICY DIRECTOR AT THE SCENE I
JANE I'M INITIATIVE ONLY A LAW
SCHOOL WE ARE A THINK TANK
WORKING TO ADVANCE POLICY THAT
ARE INTERSECTIONAL AND ADVANCE
PREVENTION RECOVERY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR SURVIVORS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. I MANY
INTENTION BEHIND THIS BILL IS TO
ENSURE THAT OUR STATE HAS A
CONSISTENT AND EQUABLE APPROACH
TO ALL FORMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING FOR ALL MINORS. OUT
ONE IMPORTANT DISTINCTION OF
CHILD LABOR TRAFFICKING AND
CHILD SEX TRAFFICKING IS THAT
FRAUD FORCED AN ORACLE- SHOULD
MUST BE PRESENT IN LABOR
TRAFFICKING. THIS DEFINITION
DERIVED FROM FEDERAL STATUTE
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
THIS MEANS THAT THIS DEFINITION
IS NARROW AND DOES NOT AFFECT
MINERS WHO MAY BE WORKING PART
TIME TO ASSIST THEIR FAMILIES OR
EVEN THOSE. THAT MAY BE. FACING. LABOR ABUSES AND EXPLOITATION
. THIS DEFINITION IS GENERALLY
ACCEPTED AND IT'S IPLIED IN
CURRENT STATE LAW IN CALIFORNIA
PENAL CODE TWO TWO TWO THREE SIX
POINT ONE. WHICH IS STAYS THAT
FORCED LABOR ALL SERVICES HAVE
TO BE THROUGH FORCE FRAUD. OR
COERCION WE BELIEVE THAT WE ARE
WILLING TO WORK. WITH FOLKS AS A
RELEASED THE CONCERNS OF THE
HAPPY WITH THIS DEFINITION TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT OUTLINES ALSO
WITH THE STATE DEFINITION. ARE
NATURALLY IS ALSO CURRENT ADVICE
ADVOCATING A PROPOSAL AUTHORED
BY A MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE.
TO ENSURE THAT THE STATE HAS A
LEAD ORGANIZATION AGE AND AGENCY
DEALS WITH LABOR TRAFFICKING FOR
ADULTS. THAT'S WHY WE ARE
DIRECTING THE AT THE DEPARTMENT
. DO I. AT THIS AGENCY PERCENT
DOES NOT PROVIDE DIRECT SERVICES
TO ADULTS OR MINORS TO CALL OSHA
WHEN IT COMES TO LABOR
TRAFFICKING THERE AND BARELY AND
THEY ONLY PROVIDE ENFORCEMENT
AND REFER CASES TO AGENCIES.
PERCENT WELL ANY PART THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT WALL THAT COULD BE ANY
PERFECT SYSTEM AND A PERFECT
BELT WE BELIEVE THAT THE CURRENT
LAW. PLACES AND- W. TO CHAO
WEALTH. TO PROTECT CHILDREN FROM
ABUSE AND NEGLECT THESE INCLUDE
CHILD LABOR TRAFFICKING AND
COMMERCIAL EXPLOITATION. JANET
AND THE CONSEQUENCES OF THE
CURRENT LAW IS THAT VICTIMS OF
LABOR TRAFFICKING ARE LACKING A
CONSISTENT. I'M APPROACH AND I
ALSO ARE MISSING OFFICE KEY
SERVICES SUCH AS TRAUMA
SERVICES. AFTER EIGHT YEARS OF
THE SISAK PROGRAM BEEN ENACTED
IN THIRTY EIGHT. COUNTIES WE
BELIEVE THAT MANY COUNTIES ARE
ALSO A BY THE FACT THAT
PROVIDING SOME SERVICES AND
IDENTIFYING SOME MINERS FOR
INSTANCE VENTURA COUNTY CHANGED
THEIR NAME AT TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT MORE BROADER. I AT SOME
COUNTIES HAVE ALSO POINT OUT OR
CREATIVE POSITIONS IN. THAT
PEOPLE WILL REFER. A CHILD LABOR
CASE IS TO THAT INDIVIDUAL SO
THEY WILL BE FLAG. AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. TERMING THAT THE
PROGRAM FUNDS MAY BE LEVERAGED
TO TRAIN SOCIAL WORKERS ON SEX
AND LABOR TRAFFICKING DOES THE
STATE ALREADY INDIRECTLY TO SOME
EXTENT PROVIDES A I'M KNOWLEDGE
IS THAT THEY MUST DO SOMETHING
TO COVER THIS POPULATION. LABOR
TRAFFICKING DISPROPORTIONATE
AFFECTS LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND IMMIGRANTS
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ENSURE THE
COMMUNITY THIS COMMUNITIES ARE
TREATED EQUALLY. LET'S NOT
FORGET THAT IF AN UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANT IS THE VICTIM OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING IS LIKE IT'S
UNLIKELY THAT THEY WILL KNOW
THEIR RIGHTS AND IT'S UNLIKELY
THAT THEY WILL ALL. SELL SICK
HELP ON THEIR OWN. LASTLY MINORS
DO NOT CHOOSE TO BE EITHER
VICTIM OF SEX LABOR TRAFFICKING
OF BOTH DOES THIS STATION NOT
TRYING TO LIMIT THE SERVICES TO
EITHER OFF. I WITH THAT HABIT WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I.
THANK YOU I KNOW WE HAVE YOUR
SECOND WITNESS- ETHAN RADIC. AND
THAT WILL BE ON THE PHONE. A
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- THIS IS ETHAN
RARICK I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SIX TWO EIGHT. THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION IS AN
INDEPENDENT OVERSIGHT AGENCY
CHARGED WITH MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE STATE
GOVERNMENT IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY WE ISSUEDA SERIES OF
THREE REPORTS EXAMINING STATE'S
RESPONSE LABOR TRAFFICKING.
PERFECT FORM OF MODERN SLAVERY
THE POINTS INNOCENT EXPLOITS IN
WORKERS REPORTS. OR COERCION
DURING OUR STUDY OF LATE
CRAFTING WE HEARD FROM A BROAD
ARRAY OF EXPERT AT. LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS AND
PORTENT EIGHT CORRECTLY FROM THE
IVR OF TRACK BUT LET TRAFFICKING
. TRAFFICKERS ON MOST OF ALL
AMONG US REGARDLESS REGARDLESS
OF GENDER AGE OR CITIZENSHIP
STATUS AND RESEARCH SUGGESTS
THAT RUN AWAY IN HOMELESS
BECAUSE WELL AS FOSTER CHILDREN
ARE PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO
THIS EXPLOITATION. YOUR
CALIFORNIA'S PROTECTIONS FOR
CHILD VICTIMS OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING PARTS IN IN OUR
REPORT LABOR TRAFFICKING
STRATEGIES TO UNCOVER THIS
HIDDEN CRIME WE FOUND THE
PROTECTIONS FOR CHILD VICTIMS
FOCUSED FAR MORE ON SEX
TRAFFICKING. COMBATING SEX
TRAFFICKING IS ABSOLUTELY VITAL
AND IT MUST CONTINUE BUT WE
BELIEVE IT IS ALSO IMPERATIVE
THAT THE STATE TARGET LABOR
TRAFFICKING JUST OF THE GRASS
ABILITY TO ENSURE CHILD VICTIMS
OF ALL FORMS OF TRAFFICKING ARE
PROTECTED BY STATE LAW. THE
COMMISSION RECOMMENDED THAT
LAWMAKERS UPDATE EXISTING LAWS
SPECIFICALLY WE RECOMMENDED THE
LAW THE HUMAN TRAFFIC COMMERCIAL
CHECKED. ALL FORMS OF. THANK
DOESN'T HEARING AGAINST WITH. AB
TWO SIX EIGHT WOULD CARRY OUT
THIS BY AS YOU KNOW. THE SEA
SECTOR TO INCLUDEALL CHILDREN
WHO ARE BIG OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
THIS WOULD INCLUDE VICTIMS OF
LABOR TRAFFICKING I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES FOR
HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE IN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SUPPORT I'M.
KEVIN OF COURSE CALIFORNIA
WELFARE RIGHTS ORGANIZATION
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. IN THE END THE SUPPORT IN
THE ROOM. K. OPERATOR WILL MOVE
TO SUPPORT ON THE PHONE.
OPERATOR ANY SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THE
ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ONE TWO FIVE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FIFTEEN CAN- WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND THE NEXT
LINE IS FOURTEEN THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AT FOURTEEN
THIRTY FIVE CAN BREED Q. WELL
MOTOR THIRTEEN FIFTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES WE CAN PLEASE GO AHEAD
SIR. THERE ARE MANY WITHOUT
GOMEZ AND I SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. IN THE NEXT ONE IN
DUBLIN NEXT LINE IS FOURTEEN
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
THIS IS MOLLY SHEEHAN WITH THE
CALIFONIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT AS AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU. WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU SESSION
WITNESSED IN PERSON HERE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM
PAULA VAZQUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY WORKS HERE WITH
THAT OF A POSITION OF OPPOSE THE
MONTH AMENDED- AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY EIGHT MAKE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO THE CURRENTLY EXIST
COMMERCIALLY SEXUALLY EXPLOITED
CHILDREN OR THE SEA SICK
PROGRAM. PRODUCING A BROAD
DEFINITION OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
WHEN SPECIFIED IN. WOULD HAVE
BEEN BEHIND THE BILL WE OPPOSE
THE PER BAN REQUESTS THAT THIS
EXPANSION BE REMOVED FROM THE
BILL. AS HAS BEEN NOTED BY
OTHERS INCLUDING BLATANT HOPE
HOOVER COMMISSION. LABOR
TRAFFICKING CONTINUES TO BE A
CRIME THAT IS NOT WELL
UNDERSTOOD OR RECOGNIZED AND-
THERE'S LITTLE AUTHORITATIVE
DATA ABOUT THE EXTENT OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING IN CALIFORNIA AND
ELSEWHERE. AND I SUSPECT THAT
HAVE OCCURRED. ADVOCATES FOR
CHILDREN HER TRAFFIC BIG WE
REVIEWED HAVE BEEN CLEARLY
DISTINGUISHED INTO TWO GROUPS.
ARE THEY CLEARLY HAVE OTHER
ABUSE NEGLECT OCCURRING THAT
WOULD BRING THEM UNDER THE WAKE
THREE DEFINITIONS WITHOUT ANY
NEED TO CHANGE. OR THERE IS NO
ABUSE CERTAIN NICKEL IN THE
ACTIVITY IDENTIFIED BY THE
TYPICALLY FALL INTO THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEMS PURVIEW AND
INSTEAD FALLS WITHIN THE PURVIEW
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR.
OPENING UP THE SEASICK PROGRAM
PROVISIONS OF WHAT CODE RELATED
TO PROTECTING CHILDREN TO A VERY
BROAD GROUP OF CHILDREN WITHOUT
CLEAR DEFINITIONS OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING. OR KNOWN CRITERIA
TO IDENTIFY CHILDREN HAS
SIGNIFICANT IMPLICATIONS AS ALSO
NOTED IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
WITHOUT A CLEAR SCHOOL PART OF.
THE SIX TEN TAKES AWAY.
PERSISTED SERVE YOU THROUGH THE
SEA SICK PROGRAM ADDITIONALLY
THAT'S BROUGHT EXPANSION COULD
EXACERBATE THE EXISTING
CHALLENGES OF A DISPROPORTIONATE
OVER REPRESENTATION OF CHILDREN
OF COLOR IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. AND ISSUE AT HAND AND
OTHER BILLS HEARD PREVIOUSLY IN
THIS HEARING. C. W. D. A.
SUPPORTS EFFORTS THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THE STATE INCLUDING
LABOR DEPARTMENT IN
COLLABORATION WITH COUNTIES TO
COLLECT SPECIFIC DATA RELATED TO
LABOR TRAFFICKING IN ORDER TO
BETTER INFORM AN APPROPRIATE
POLICY RESPONSE. WE SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THE MAJORITY LEADER
AND HER STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THIS BILL AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED DISCUSSION.
MASSPORT THANK YOU DO WE HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. JUST
BEEN SHOPPERS OKAY ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. CASING
NONE BUT ANY OPPOSITION- ONLINE
OPERATORS. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
FEAR IN OPPOSITION. AND WE DO
HAVE LINE THIRTEEN FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I BET ON THE
OUTCOME OF THE LIKE THE PROJECT-
BIRTH BECAUSE THAT I'M CHANGING
MY- SUPPORT BUT THIS BILL TO
OPPOSE. FROM WHAT THE PREVIOUS-
WITNESS JUST THE SAID HELLO YEAH
I OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE NEXT LINE IS
FORTINO TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
MATERNAL LINE OF FOURTEEN FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MOMENTOUS
DAY WITH AN OPERATOR. FOURTEEN
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I
AM OPPOSED TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU ONE MOTOR LINE UP FOURTEEN
OH TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
PARTICULARLY FROM LOS ANGELES
DEPENDENCY LAWYERS AND WE OPPOSE
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY AT THE TIME
. THANK YOU FOURTEEN FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
THE THAT COMPANY AND I OPPOSE A.
B. TWO TWO TWO THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU M. FOURTEEN FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NAY TOOK
THEIR STEP BY TO Q. ONE MOMENT.
WELL MOVE TO THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
DENIS WOULD DECIMATE BOTH THE
CURRENT BILL. Q. THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS JOE CRANE- AND I OPPOSE
THE CURRENT BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU MAMA MOVED TO
FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS THE RANGE. AND
I OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE FELL. THANK YOUNG WOMAN TO
THE LINE OF FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
LOOKED AT MY DAD AND I ARE BOTH
THE BILL. THANK YOU AND ONE
MOMENT WE HAVE A FEW WITH
APPARATUS EVERYONE OUT THERE
WITH AN OPERATOR. PERHAPS THE
CAN BE ANOTHER NELSON BY THE
OPERATOR ON THE BILL WERE ON.
WHAT IS THE OPERATING CARE
GUARDING OF THE BILL CERTAINLY.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE ON AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY EIGHT IN OPPOSITION
ANYONE ELSE ONLINE THANK YOU. WE
DO WE HAVE LINE FOURTEEN FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS CHERYL OCCUR AND I'M
OPPOSING BILL FORTY. BILL TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. AGAIN WE'RE ON
BILL AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT
FOR OPPOSITION THANK YOU. OKAY
THAT WAS THE LAST PERSON IN Q.
THANK YOU. YEAH COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS THIS
GIPSON. BRENT SORRY FOR MY
SCREENS SHOULD NEVER BRINGS THE
L. I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HER INTENTIONS- AND
THOUGHTS BEHIND THIS BILL AND- I
KNOW THAT THE OPPOSITION'S
COMMENTS HAVE BEEN WELL HEARD
AND I KNOW THAT YOU WORK ALL THE
WAY THROUGH THIS PROCESS AND SO
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. ANY OTHER COMMENTS GET I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILLS WELL I DON'T THINK
PEOPLE REALIZE HOW PREVALENT OF
LABOR TRAFFICKING IS JUST LIKE
SEXUAL TRAFFICKING SO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS AND I'D LIKE
TO CO AUTHOR THANK YOU. WOULD
WELCOME YOU. THANK YOU. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE WILL- AS MY COLLEAGUE HAS
INDICATED WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH C. W. DA. TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS LABOR TRAFFICKING
IS A SERIOUS ISSUE OUR CHILDREN
NEED TO BE PROTECTED. IT ISN'T
JUST SEX TRAFFICKING LABOR
TRAFFICKING IS IMPORTANT AND
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION HAS
MADE IT CLEAR WITH. THE REPORT
THEY PREPARED AND THIS IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT THE
CHILDREN. TO RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. MAKE A MOTION
SEVEN. OKAY. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CALDERON CALDERON AYE
DAVIES DAVIES I ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI BONTA HI BONTA HI
BRIAN HI BRIAN ICE STONE STONE I
VIA HUDA YOU PUT A AYE WALDRON.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA HAVE THANK YOU
IF SOMEONE BURKE IN A LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN THANK YOU THANK. OKAY
ADD NEXT ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
ARE YOU READY TO PRESENT ON AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHT. SHARE
GOOD AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES IT'S
GREAT TO SEE EVERYBODY OUR FIRST
LIKE TO THANK OUR COMMITTEE
STAFF. FOR THE WORK ON THE
ANALYSIS REALLY APPRECIATE. THE
ANALYSIS THE COMMENTS- AND I'M
HERE TO PRESENT SOME THE BILL
ONE SEVEN TWO EIGHT WHICH SEEKS
TO EXEMPT PARENTS OR- CAREGIVERS
. WHO ARE RECEIVING CALYX
BENEFITS- WITH CHILDREN THREE
YEARS OF AGE OR YOUNGER FROM
MANDATORY PARTICIPATION IN
WELFARE TO WORK PROGRAMS-
CURRENTLY UNDER EXISTING LAW
PARENTS IN THE CAL WORKS SYSTEM.
MUST RETURN TO A WELFARE TO WORK
ACTIVITIES. UNLESS THEY FORMALLY
REQUEST A ONE TIME TWENTY FOUR
MONTH EXEMPTION AND THIS ONE
TIME IS A LIFETIME EXEMPTION-
IT'S A REQUESTED THIS ONE TIME
EXEMPTION INVOLVES A LENGTHY
PROCESS THAT IS OFTENTIMES IN
ASSESSABLE FOR MANY FAMILIES-
AND THAT'S BECAUSE THE OUR
LOCATION PROCESS FOR SUCH
EXEMPTIONS IS CONVOLUTED IT
REQUIRES EITHER IN PERSON OR
OVER THE PHONE CONSULTATIONS AND
MEETINGS. AND AVAILABILITY OF
SUCH RESOURCES- VARIES FROM EACH
COUNTY TO COUNTY. STATION SEEKS
TO PROVIDE AN AUTOMATIC WELL FOR
TO WORK EXEMPTION FOR PARENTS OR
CAREGIVERS. CARE FOR CHILDREN
THREE YEARS OF AGE AND YOUNGER.
SOME PARENTING RESARCH SCIENCE
HAS MADE VERY VERY CLEAR- THE
IMPORTANCE OF EARLY BINDING ON
THE LONG TERM MENTAL HEALTH AND
RESILIENCE OF CHILDREN. AS WE
KNOW THEN SEE AND THE FIRST
YEARS OF A CHILD'S LIFE IS A
CRUCIAL TIME FOR THEIR- BRAIN-
SOME DEVELOPMENT. ONE PREVIOUS
STUDY FACT. GOOD INITIAL BOND
CHILDREN ARE LESS LIKELY TO GROW
UP TO BECOME HAPPY. INDEPENDENT
AND RESILIENT ADULTS YOU KNOW AS
A RESULT. THROUGH THAT WE DO ALL
THAT WE CAN TO SUPPORT- THESE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT FOSTER
PROMOTE MEANINGFUL ATTACHMENT-
BETWEEN BABIES AND YOUNG
CHILDREN AND THEIR PARENTS WILL
GO A LONG WAY TO SUPPORT THEIR
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL AND COGNITIVE
ON. THE DEVELOPMENT- AND SO WITH
ME HERE TO TESTIFY IS KEVIN- AS
LANYON ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA WELFARE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS THANK YOU
MANAGER. I COULD HAVE ANOTHER
COURSE OF CALIFORNIA WELFARE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION. THE AUTHOR
PRETTY WILL PRESENT THE BILL
VERY ELOQUENTLY- DURING THE
SCHWARZENEGGER ADMINISTRATION WE
ACTION BECAUSE THAT THAT
EVERYBODY ON THE THREE. AND THEN
SOMEHOW THAT CAME BACK IN THIS
SPACE IN THIS BILL WITH SAY
EVERYBODY'S ARE MAGNIFICENT THAT
AND BUT IF THEY WANT TO
PARTICIPATE THE WELL FOR THE
WORK PROGRAM THEY WOULD GET A
LETTER AND THEY COULD FIND MARK
THE BOX SEVEN PARTICIPATES IN
THAT BACK AND THEN THEY GET TO
PARTICIPATE. IN THAT THE- NEVER
HEARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OKAY I'M GONNA OPEN IT UP FOR-
PRIMARY. WORK IN THE ROOM. GOOD
FOR. GO AHEAD RESPOND TO THE
BOTTOM OF THE WEBSITE ALL
ALREADY OR SOMETHING FOR. THANK
YOU TO HAVE ANY SUPPORT IN THE
ROOM. OKAY SEEN NINE OPERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR. THAT PUBLIC SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU AND IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE WILL GO
TO THE LINE OF THIRTEEN ELEVEN
ONE MOMENT. LOCAL CAROLINA
THIRTEEN ELEVEN. I'M SORRY VOTE
TO FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FIND FOURTEEN
THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF
THE MACINNES ON BEHALF OF FIRST
FIVE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
WEBER. I'M SORRY WILL MOVE TO
THIRTEEN ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. YOUR CALL ABOUT THE NURSE
CALIFORNIA INSTRUCTABLE THANKS.
WITH WITH WITH THE- THANK YOU
WERE MOVED TO TWELVE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DURING DINNER
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ONE MOVED TO TWELVE SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JOSELYN LOPEZ I LOOK AT
IT FOR THE FACT AND I AM IN
STRONG THE COURT THANK YOU.
THANK AND AT THIS TIME THERE'S
NO ONE I THINK YOU. THANK YOU
OPERATOR- NEXT WILL GO TO- ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM DO WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION AGAINST A AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINE. OR TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT. MICHAEL FIFTEEN
NINE OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE FOR ANY OPPOSITION
TO AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHT.
AND IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
AND IF YOU'RE OPPOSED PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO MOVE THE
BILL SECOND. WE HAVE ONE PERSON
IN Q. THANK YOU FOR. YOU'RE
WELCOME ONE MOMENT. AS LINE
FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES OUR KILL THE BILL AB
TWO TWO TWO THREE FOUR THANK YOU
ARE ON AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
. HOWEVER REGARDING S. TWO TWO
ALL RIGHT- BUT YEAH WE ARE AB
SEVEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT MA'AM- SEVENTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT OKAY SEVERAL WAYS TO GO TO
LUNCH I CALL. OPERATOR NEXT IS
THERE ANYBODY ELSE IN THE QUEUE
AND THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU THANK YOU OPERATOR. OKAY DO
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY SEEN NINE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SOME OF
MEMBERS BUT THAT'S WHEN I VOTE
THANK YOU OKAY CABALLERO. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CALDERON CALDERON AYE
DAVIES DAVIES NOW ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI BONTA. HI BONTA HI
BRIAN. RYAN ICE STONE STONE IV
ABUJA THE ABUJA HI. WALDRON.
OKAY- OKAY WILLIE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AMBULANCE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PRESENT ON AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY THREE. THE BILL. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT ON AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY THREE TODAY. AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY THREE STRETCHES THE
DOLLARS OF CAL FRESH RECIPIENTS
EVEN FURTHER BY COMBINING
SUCCESSFUL FRUIT AND VEGETABLE
SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFIT PROGRAMS
WITH THE EFFICIENCY OF THE
CALIFORNIA EBT SYSTEM.
CALIFORNIANS ARE FACING FOOD
INSECURITY AT ALARMING RATES AT
THE START OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
ONE IN TEN CALIFORNIANS HAD
DIFFICULTY PUTTING FOOD ON THE
TABLE. IT IS EVEN MORE DIFFICULT
FOR LOW. THREE FINDING
AFFORDABLE FRUITS AND VEGETABLES
THE RESEARCH SHOWS THAT WE CAN
CHANGE THIS. WHEN PEOPLE HAVE
THE MONEY TO PURCHASE FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES THEY DO. A NUMBER OF
PROGRAMS AROUND THE STATE
PROVIDE DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR MATCH
TO CALFRESH RECIPIENTS AT
FARMERS MARKETS THIS IS TERMED
SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFITS THEY NOT
ONLY SUPPORT HEALTHY EATING
HABITS AND INCREASED THE
PURCHASING POWER FOR THOSE WHO
ARE AND REST ENROLLED IN
CALFRESH. BUT THEY ALSO DIRECTLY
BENEFIT CALIFORNIA'S FARMERS. AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE
RECOGNIZES THE IMMENSE POTENTIAL
BENEFIT OF THESE PROGRAMS AND
MEETS CALFRESH RECIPIENTS WHERE
THEY NORMALLY PURCHASE PRODUCE.
THE EXPANSION THIS BILL PROPOSES
WOULD BRING SUPPLEMENTAL
BENEFITS TO LARGE RETAIL CHAINS
TO CORNER STORES AND TWO OTHER
DIRECT FARM TO CONSUMER ENTITIES
THAT SELL CALIFORNIA GROWN
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES.
IMPORTANTLY THIS BILL LEVERAGES
THE EFFICIENCY OF THE EBT CARDS
ALREADY USED BY CALFRESH
RECIPIENTS TO REDUCE HASSLE AND
MAKE ACCESSING FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES THAT MUCH EASIER FOR
FAMILIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA. I'M
JOINED TODAY BY E. Y. Z. GAS
REPRESENTING SPUR AND BY DAVID
BARBER DUNN HAM A PARTICIPANT IN
THE MONSTROUS GOAL PROGRAM IN
SAN DIEGO. RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON
CHECK CALDERON AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ELISA
GUESTS AND THE FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE POLICY DIRECTOR AT
CBRE- AND ON ON BEHALF OF SPUR
AS WELL AS NOURISH CALIFORNIA
ARE CO SPONSORING THIS I WANT TO
THANK DR ARAMBULA FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY THREE. WE'RE EXCITED
BECAUSE THIS BILL WOULD DO THREE
THINGS IT REDUCES HUNGER IT
IMPROVES HEALTH AND IT SUPPORTS
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMY. IT DOES THAT BY
PROVIDING CALFRESH CLIENTS WITH
FRUIT AND VEGETABLE SUPPLEMENTAL
BENEFITS WHEN THEY PURCHASE
CALIFORNIA GROWN FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES AT PARTICIPATING
GROCERY STORES AND FARMERS
MARKETS. SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
WHAT IT DOES IS EXPAND THE
NUMBER OF RETAILERS RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE PROGRAMS DOUBLE UP FOOD
BUCKS YOU'RE GONNA HEAR ABOUT
MAS FRESCO MARKET MATCH AND A
NUMBER OF OTHERS OPERATING IN
THE STATE- BUT IT ONLY REACHES
SO MANY PEOPLE. AND THERE'S A
PILOT FROM A BILL. FROM TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THAT IS AGAIN EXPANDED
A LITTLE BIT WITH THE B. T.
INTEGRATION AND THIS IS GOING TO
TAKE IT MUCH FURTHER BECAUSE WE
KNOW THERE ARE MANY CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE STRUGGLING. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA SPOKE ABOUT THAT
BUT I WOULD JUST EMPHASIZE WE
ARE. AS YOU WELL KNOW WELL
FACING HISTORIC LEVELS OF HUNGER
AND FOOD INSECURITY- AND WE
BELIEVE THIS PROGRAM. WILL GO A
LONG WAY TO SUPPORTING THE FOOD
ASSISTANCE SAFETY NET. AND WHILE
CALTRAIN AS IT IS HELPS MANY WE
KNOW THERE'S A BENEFITS CLIFF
COMING THEIR EMERGENCY
ALLOTMENTS COMING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT ARE SET
TO EXPIRE. AND WE THINK THIS
PROGRAM CAN HELP MITIGATE THAT
SO PEOPLE CAN HAVE. A LITTLE BIT
MORE MONEY TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
FOR THEIR FOR THEIR FAMILIES. WE
ALSO KNOW THIS PROGRAMS PROVEN
TO WORK- WE DO RESEARCH FOR OUR
OWN PROGRAM DOUBLE UP FOOD
BUCKS- THAT WE DO IN THE BAY
AREA. BUT THAT'S TRUE NATIONALLY
AND- MANY OTHER PROGRAMS AGAIN
REDUCING HUNGER IMPROVING
NUTRITION AND SUPPORTING FRUIT
VEGETABLE FARMERS. AND LASTLY I
DO WANT TO HIT ON THIS. POINT
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER ENDLESS
SAID 97% OF THE FUNDS THAT ARE
PROPOSED IN THIS BILL WOULD. BE
INTO PEOPLE'S POCKETS THIS.
CREDIBLY ADMINISTRATIVELY
EFFICIENT. ANOTHER REASON WE ARE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS BECAUSE
IT'S INTEGRATED INTO THE EBT
SYSTEM. SO I JUST WANNA AND BY
SAYING WHAT YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF
YOU AS A WIN WIN WIN. WITH A
BROAD COALITION OF SUPPORT IT'S
A WIN ON HUNGER IT'S A WIN ON
HEALTH AND IT'S A WIN FOR THE
AGRICULTURAL. ECONOMY OF
CALIFORNIA SO URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES ON TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE.
AND MAKE HEALTHY FOOD MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH
LOW INCOME THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OPERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR THE NEXT OUR
PRIMARY WITH. PORT I DAVID
BARBER DENIM. ONE MONTH YOUR
LINE IS OPEN TO. THANK YOU SHARE
CALDERON AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM DAVID BARBER
DONALD BARRIO LOGAN SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA. I AM ON A LIMITED
INCOME WAS SO SECURITY AND HAVE
HEALTH CONDITIONS BECAUSE OF
WORK IN THE LABOR FORCE HERE.
EIGHT FOUR MONTHS GO I WAS
LIVING ON CARE OF BIRTHDAY
BECAUSE MORE THE MOST SHOULD.
CHECK TO PAY RENT. MY DOCTOR
PRESCRIBED THAT I COULD NOT
AFFORD. FOR MOSCOW SCHOOL ME BY
THE SEVEN DOCTOR RECORD. BECAUSE
I WAS ABLE TO BUY HEALTHY. A LOT
WEIGHT LOWERED MICHAELA. AND GOT
MORE LIFE THAT MUCH BE HAS BEEN
SO GOOD TO ME AND I FEEL THAT IT
SHARED BY LAW. I STRUGGLED WITH
THE- BILL O ONE THREE. I THANK
YOU FOR THE ARE. TO TEST THE TO
THE- I'M HAPPY THEY HAVE ANY
QUESTION. THANK SIR I KNOW OPEN
IT UP TO- SIDE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF A TWENTY FIFTY THREE
CHRIS. POLICY WITH THE CENTER
LAMPARD IN STRONG. THANK YOU.
OKAY SENAD NOTICE THE ROOM
OPERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE PHONE LINES FOR PUBLIC.
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
THREE. THANK YOU IF YOU WERE IN
THREE PLEASE PRESS A ONE THEN
ZERO. M. OF GO TO THE LINE OF
FOURTEEN FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THANK YOU SO THE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WELL MOVED TO THE LINE OF
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS HEIDI MAKE YOU
WITH FOOD FOR PEOPLE THE FOOD
BANK FOR HUMBOLDT COUNTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND
WILL MOVE TO THIRTEEN FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
SYSTEM WILL CUT THEM WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
THREE THANK YOU. WILL MOVE TO
THIRTEEN ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TEN THIRTEEN ELEVEN YOUR OPEN. WELL MOVED TO FOURTEEN FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TAYLOR RUSSIAN WITH A
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOUNG
WILL MOVE TO LINE TWELVE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU CAN-
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
WERE MOVED TO FOURTEEN FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS WITH THE
SUGAR SEE WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION A STRONG
SUPPORT. M. WILL MOVE TO
FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JAMIE
WORKING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION
IMPORTANT STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND LINE THIRTEEN
ELEVEN YOUR OPEN. THIRTEEN
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MATT
HAVE YOU MEET THAT NINE. AND
THAT WAS THE LAST THING Q. THANK
YOU OPERATOR- OKAY NOW WILL GO
TO ANY OPPOSITION DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. SCENE
NINE OPERATOR CAN YOU OPEN THE
LINE TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY THREE. THANK YOU AND
AFFAIRS CALLING PLEASE. PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AND THIS IS FOR
A. B. TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE.
FAN AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
IN Q. THANK YOU OKAY WILL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD WE'RE ABLE TO PASS A
CALFRESH BILL LAST YEAR THAT
REALLY HELPED OUT STUDENTS AS
WELL AS- A LOT OF FOSTER KIDS.
SO I THINK THIS IS A GREAT STEP
HERE IN LAKE CITY IT'S YOU KNOW
YOU'RE YOU'RE DECIDING WHETHER
OR NOT YOU'RE GOING TO BE.
GETTING SOME THAT'S NOT
NUTRITION BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
AFFORD ANYTHING ELSE NOW THEY
HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY SO REALLY
IS A WIN WIN. AND I WOULD BE
HONORED TO HAVE WOULD BE A CO
AUTHOR ON THIS. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE- I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS MATTER FORWARD. IT'S A
GREAT. GREAT BILL AND I WOULD
LIKE TO BE A CO AUTHOR.
ABSOLUTELY MADAM CHAIR OKAY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. BOB
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NINE. OKAY THANK YOU. HELLO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE
CALDERON AYE CALDERON AYE DAVIES
DAVIES I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI
BONTA HI BONTA HI BRIAN. BRIAN
AYE STONE STONE I ENVY ABUJA YOU
PUT AYE WALDRON. THANK YOU. OKAY
I ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT ON AB TWENTY
EIGHT OH SIX. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT OH SIX IN FRONT OF THE
COMMUNITY- THE COMMITTEE TODAY
AB TWENTY EIGHT OH SIX WILL
GREATLY LIMIT THE SUSPENSION AND
EXPULSION OF PRESCHOOL AGE
STUDENTS. WHEN AS EARLY WARNING
SYSTEM AND YES LET ME SAY THAT
AGAIN. PRESCHOOLERS ARE BEING
EXPELLED- IN THE EAST AND THE
AND NATIONAL DATA HAS INDICATED
TO VERY CONCERNING TRENDS IN
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION. NOT
ONLY ARE THE STARS SUSPENSIONS
AND EXPULSIONS MORE COMMON THE
PRESCHOOL SETTING THAN IN K.
TWELVE. THEY ALSO
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
CHILDREN OF COLOR. RESEARCH HAS
ALSO INDICATED SCHOOL EXPULSIONS
AND SUSPENSIONS PRACTICES ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH NEGATIVE
EDUCATIONAL AND LIFE OUTCOMES.
IN ADDITION TO HARMING A YOUNG
CHILD'S ACADEMIC PROSPECTS BASED
RESEARCH. HAS ALSO FOUND THAT
SUSPENSIONS AND EXPULSIONS DO
NOTHING TO IMPACT THE ROOT CAUSE
OF CHALLENGING BEHAVIOR. IN
ADDITION TO IDENTIFYING AND
DEFINING PROBLEMS. IN
CALIFORNIA'S PRESCHOOL SYSTEM
THE BILL ALSO IS. DESIGNED TO
CREATE A PUT UP. PROACTIVE
SOLUTION. AND WE ARE DOING THIS
THROUGH THE USE OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH CONSERVE
CONSULTATIONS. OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS EASY M. H. C. ECM H. C.
SERVER ARE APPROVING MODEL WAY
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL AND
TREE PRESCHOOL SETTING AND
PROVIDE SUPPORT TO THE STUDENT.
THE STAFF AND THE FAMILIES- I
CAN TELL YOU FROM EXPERIENCE
THAT THE TEACHER OF MY TRAINING
DID NOT INCLUDE MENTAL HEALTH-
TO PROVIDE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH AND THIS. BILL
AIMS TO PROVIDE THAT SUPPORT NOT
JUST TO THE FAMILY BUT AND THE
STUDENT BUT ALSO TO. TO THE
STAFF MEMBERS THAT ARE ARE- WITH
THE CHILD EVERY DAY. THESE
SERVICES CREATE A MEANS OF
PROVIDING ADEQUATE SUPPORT TO
TEACHERS CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
IN ORDER TO PROMOTE POSITIVE
MENTAL HEALTH. BUFFER THE
EFFECTS OF TOXIC STRESS AND
TRAUMA AND BRING OUT THE MOST
OPTIMAL DEVELOPMENT AND LEARNING
OF EACH AND EVERY CHILD. SO WITH
THIS BILL WE ARE NOT SIMPLY
TRYING TO HAND OFF PROVIDERS-
SORRY. SIMPLY NOT TYING THE
HANDS OF PROVIDERS BY LIMITING
SUSPENSIONS AND EXPULSIONS WE'RE
ALSO PROVIDING THEM WITH A NEW
TOOL TO HELP ADDRESS CHALLENGING
BEHAVIOR. IN A MORE HOLISTIC AND
POSITIVE MANNER THIS LEGISLATION
HAS HAD INPUT FROM POLICY
EXPERTS THROUGHOUT OUR NATION
AND ENJOYS A LARGE AMOUNT OF
SUPPORT. THE BILL HAS A WIDE
COALITION OF SUPPORT IS- IT IS
THE INCLUDING IN THE GOVERNOR'S
EARLY I'M SORRY IT IS INCLUDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S EARLY LEARNING
AND CARE MASTER PLAN RELEASED
EARLIER LAST YEAR. AND HAS NO
KNOWN OPPOSITION. ON THE PHONE
WITH US TODAY WE HAVE SOME OF
OUR CO SPONSORS THANK YOU IT AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
BOUGHT. OKAY THANK YOU OPPER
COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINE FOR A PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY EIGHT OH
SIX. IN THEIR LINE UP THAT'S.
GOOD CAN EVERYONE HEAR ME YES GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS ACCEPTABLE AND LIVE IN
OAKLAND IN DISTRICT EIGHTEEN I'M
A FRANKLY CUBICLE CHILDREN BEING
A WORKING MOM I ALWAYS NEED A
RELIABLE AFFORDABLE AND HIGH
QUALITY CHILDCARE. WHEN I HAD MY
FUN BUMPED OUR LOWS IT WAS
REALLY CHALLENGING FOR ME TO
FIND CHILD CARE FOR BOTH OF MY
CHILDREN MY DAUGHTER WAS IN PAIN
AND THERE WERE NOT MANY
CHARACTERS WELL. I ENDED UP A
HOME CHILDCARE. AFTER LESS THAN
A WEEK THAT MY CHILDREN WERE
THERE AT THE PROVIDER. ME YOU
COULD NOT CARE FOR MY SPENDING
IN MARIN JEFF MY SON. THAT THEY
I COULDN'T UNDERSTAND WHY HE
DIDN'T WANT TO TAKE CARE OF MY
SON ANYMORE. SHE ALREADY HAD ALL
OF HIS BELONGINGS PACKED UP AND
I WAS AT THE STATE. AND WAIT
UNTIL THE PARENTS PICKED UP
THEIR CHILDREN. BECAUSE SHE
NEEDED TO TALK TO ME SHE SAID
THAT HE WITH THE KOBE LONG BUT I
NEVER GOT A CALL FROM HER NOT A
NOT A PARTY. HOWEVER WHEN I SAW
HIM AND PICKED HIM UP HE WAS NOT
RESPONDING. I NEED A LATE SECOND
TO CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IN
OAKLAND WHERE AFTER PERFORMING A
CT SCAN THEY FOUND THAT HE HAD A
SUBDURAL HEMATOMA AND MULTIPLE
RETINAL HEMORRHAGE. AT THAT
MOMENT MY CAME. DOWN IT WAS
UNTIL I AM OLD CHILDREN INTO AYE
HOW QUALITY CENTER FOR PROGRAM
BUT I BEGAN FEEL THE THEM UP.
THE PENTAGON. CHAU THAT THE CARE
OF THE KIDS THAT OWN. THEY ALSO
OFFERED ME- EARLY TALK MENTAL
HEALTH ON. SERVICE THAT. WHAT
THE COMPLICATION ONLY THE COME
WORK WITH MY SON AT THE
CONSULTANT WORK AND BETWEEN THE
TWO GROUPS THAT WORK WITH HIM IN
THE CLASSROOM AND SHE ALSO
WORKED WITH ME THE MOM. I'M FROM
HOME. CHAPTER MUST HAVE WAYS TO
COMMUNICATE WITH FAMILY WITHOUT
HAVING TO MAKE THEM FEEL LIKE
THEY DON'T BELONG. WE NEED A
BETTER PROCESS TO ADDRESS THE
HAVERTON CHILD CARE AND
PRESCHOOL. AND WE NEED A
HOLISTIC APPROACH THAT CONSIDERS
THE WHOLE CHILD AND THE WELL
BEING OF TEACHERS AND PARENTS.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING AB
TWENTY EIGHT OKAY. THANK YOU. ON
AVERAGE AFTERNOON THANK YOU.
NINETEEN A CLONE SITES PRESIDENT
OF EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATION IT CAN GO HANG
THOSE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR AB.
TWENTY EIGHT OH SIX. NOW ALL OF
US PRESENT TODAY FEEL THE STRAIN
OF THE LAST FEW YEARS. OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
EXPERIENCE DEEPLY COMPOUNDED
HARDSHIP. ON TOP OF IT BIRTH THE
FAITH ALREADY PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC. THIS IS ALSO TRUE
WITHIN OUR EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION SETTING TEACHER THAN
PROVIDERS.WERE ALREADY
STRETCHED AND STRETCHED TO THEIR
LIMIT BEFORE. I CAN TELL YOU
PERSONALLY THAT THEY ARE EVEN
MORE WORN DOWN OVERWHELMED AND
DESPERATE. CHILDREN IN OUR
CLASSROOMS A CHILD CARE HOMES
ALREADY HAD ENCOUNTERED
INCREDIBLE STRATHEARN. THEY'VE
ABSORBED EVEN MORE TOXIC STRESS
AND STRAIN TRAUMA COMPOUNDED BY
MORE TRAUMA. FAILURE TO RESPOND
NOW WITH ADEQUATE HELP HE
RECIEVED WILL COME AT A HUGE
COST WITH LASTING IMPACT. WON'T
IMPACT BEING FURTHER EXPULSION
OF OUR ALREADY VULNERABLE YOUNG
CHILDREN. FORTUNATELY THERE IS A
RESOURCE THAT ALREADY EXIST THAT
IS DESIGNED TO ADDRESS THE
COMPLEX CHALLENGES FACED TODAY
WITH AN EASY. AND THAT IT'S
EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATION. EARLY CHILDHOOD
MENTAL HEALTH CONSULTATION BRING
SCIENCE READ AT THE PORT TO
ADDRESS THE INTERCONNECTED WHOLE
PERSON NEEDS OF TEACHERS
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN. QUALITY
COMPREHENSIVE CONSULTATION HE
QUIPPED CAN SUPPORT THAT MANAGE
TRADERS EARLY EDUCATORS AND
PROVIDERS TO BE WELL THEMSELVES
. WHILE ALSO HELPING TWELVE
QUICK FEES ADULTS SHOULD BE ABLE
TO RESPOND TO THE MENTAL
EMOTIONAL AND BEHAVIORAL NEEDS
OF CHILDREN IN THEIR CARE. NOW
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
CONSULTATION IS DIRECTLY
CONNECTED TO THE COMPETENCY OF
THE CONSULTANTS WORK FORCE.
CONSULTANT NOT HAVE SPECIFIC
SKILLS AND EXPERTISE THAT IS
UNIQUE EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL
HEALTH. AND CAN ADDRESS THE
COMPLEXITIES INHERENT IN THE
WORK OF CONSULTATION. SH AB
TWENTY EIGHT OH SIX OUTLINES THE
SPECIALIZED EDUCATION TRAINING
SUPERVISION AND ONGOING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT THAT IS
IMPERATIVE. I CANNOT EMPHASIZE
ENOUGH HOW CRITICAL THE TRAINING
EXPERIENCE AND ONGOING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT IT IS
THE QUALITY AND EFFECTIVENESS OF
EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATION. PLEASE SUPPORT AB
TWENTY EIGHT ARCHITECT YOUR
SUPPORT MORE DIRECTLY INFLUENCED
YOUNG VULNERABLE CHILDREN ACROSS
OUR STATE AND THEN GETTING THE
CARE THEY DESERVE BY TEACHERS
PROVIDERS AND FAMILIES WHO HAVE
THE SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I'M GONNA
OPEN IT UP TO ANY SUPPORT- IN
THE ROOM DO WE HAVE ANY SUPPORT
FOR AB TWENTY EIGHT OF SIX IN
THE ROOM. OKAY SEEN NINE
OPERATOR COULD YOU OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
EIGHT OH SIX. THANK YOU AND IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
EIGHT OH SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND WILL MOVE TO THE
LINE OF TWELVE SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS DONNA CALLING
ON ON BEHALF OF FIGHT CRIME
INVESTING KIDS AND COUNCIL FIRST
GENERIKA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
FOR VOTER THIRTEEN OH TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HASN'T YET IN
MY YOUNG WITH POLITICAL SOLUTION
. CALLING ON BEHALF OF SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AND
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND THE
NEXT LINE IS FOURTEEN SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS ANA CASTRO NINE- BUT THE
THING OF THE CITY OF SAN JOSE
AND I'M CALLING TO OPPOSE A. B.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE OKAY
WE'RE ON AB TWENTY EIGHT OH SIX.
OPERATOR COULD YOU GO TO THE
NEXT CALL OKAY. WELL MOVE
CAROLINE OF. TWELVE FIFTY THREE.
HELLO THIS IS MY ASIA WHERE'S
KIDDING GO AND IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT OKAY. THANK
YOU I'M OF CAROLINA. FOURTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
SLOWLY MCKAY CALLING ON BEHALF
OF BURKE BACK CALIFORNIA IN THE
PORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU HOME
OF THE LINE OF TWELVE FIFTY NINE
. HI THIS IS JIM KEENER ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND FOURTEEN SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SENATE BILL ON
BEHALF OF THE CESSATION
CALIFORNIA'S OWN ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU THANK YOU
OPERATOR OKAY NOW- DO WE HAVE
ANY- OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT
TWENTY. EIGHT OH SIX IN THE ROOM
. SEEING NONE I DO WE HAVE
OPERATOR CAN YOU OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR ANY OPPOSITION TO AB.
TWENTY EIGHT OH SIX. IF YOU'RE
IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY
EIGHT OH SIX PLEASE PRESS THE
ONE THEN ZERO NEXT AB. TWENTY
EIGHT OH SIX. NO ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OPERATOR OKAY WE'LL
BRING YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR.
THE AUTHOR. WHEN I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THI FORWARD
WE HAD A COUPLE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THIS VERY SAME THING AND-
YOU AND I ARE BOTH CHAMPIONS OF
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND
CHILD CARE AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE- THE FACT THAT WE
ACTUALLY HAD SEVERAL
CONSTITUENTS OF MINE IN EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN COLIN IN SUPPORT OF
THIS AND THAT MEANS A GREAT DEAL
IS TO AS WELL SO. WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION. I THINK
WE OP ALREADY HAD A MISSION BUT
I WILL OBVIOUSLY BE SUPPORTING
SMALL. WE FEEL LIKE TO CLOSE
WITH. THE EXCUSE ME THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THE SUPPORT- YOU
KNOW AS WE UNDERSTAND. YOU KNOW
WE CAN TALK ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES- BUT- IF WE START IN
PEACE GOAL. IMAGINE HOW AMAZING
THEIR FEET THE KIDS FUTURE WOULD
BE MAKING SURE THAT THEY HAVE-THE SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED AND-
AS A FORMER TEACHER. HOW AMAZING
MY FUTURE WOULD HAVE BEEN IF I
HAD THAT MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATIONS EARLY ON SOUTH.
THANK YOU FOR IF YOU MAY NOT BE
HERE BUT- THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU HE CALDERON. THE
MOTION IS PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. CALDERON HI
CALDERON I'D- ALONG WITH THAT.
FIVE DAVIS I ARAMBULA. BONTA AYE
BONTA AYE BRIAN HI BRIAN NICE
DOWN STONE IV ABUJA YOU PUT AYE
AND WALDRON. THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE OPEN. OKAY AT THE MOMENT
STONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT
ON AB TWO SEVEN EIGHT SIX. IS
THAT. THE BILL OKAY. SECOND.
OKAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
VENTURE IN MEMBERS. THE RIGHT
FORM HERE. SO ABOUT EIGHTEEN
MONTHS AGO OR SO THERE WAS A BIT
OF A CRISIS WITH. LOT OF THE
FOSTER YOUTH AND PROVISION IF
WE'VE BEEN SENDING OUT OF THE
STATE AND THEY WERE BROUGHT BACK
INTO THE STATE AND WHAT THAT
REALLY SHOWED WAS THE LACK OF
CRISIS CARE FOR SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE KIDS KIDS WITH THE
HIGHEST NEEDS. THERE IS AN
EFFORT LAST YEAR THAT WE RAN IN
AND UP WORKING THROUGH THE
BUDGET. THAT DEVELOP A
CONTINUUM. ACROSS THE CONTINUUM
PILOT PROGRAM FOR THOSE KIDS.
AND WHAT AB TWENTY SEVENTY SIX
DOES NOW IS IT IT EXPANDS THOSE
PILOTS. TWO KIDS ON MEDICARE. SO
THAT DOESN'T WE DON'T. WE NEED
TO SUPPORT KIDS IN CRISIS.
REGARDLESS OF HOW WE CATEGORIZE
THEM WHETHER THEIR PROBATION
WHETHER THEIR DEPENDENCY. OR ANY
OTHER HOMELESS AT ANY OTHER
CATEGORY WHAT WE NEED TO DO SO
IS PROVIDE SUPPORTS FOR KIDS AS
THEY NEEDED THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS DOING IS EXPANDING THAT
CRISIS CAPACITY TO KIDS ON
OUTSIDE OF THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. REALLY TO ALL KIDS AND
KIDS WHO ARE MEDICARE ELIGIBLE
SO IT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
WE'RE WORKING PRETTY CLOSELY
WITH DSS AND WITH THE H. C. S.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE COULD PUT
SOMETHING TOGETHER THAT THEY CAN
IN FACT IMPLEMENT. AND WE'RE
ALSO WORKING TO. MAKE SURE WE
HAVE A BUDGET COMPONENT TO THIS
AS WELL AS WE DID LAST YEAR IT
WAS A VERY SUCCESSFUL EFFORT TO
DEAL WITH KIDS. AT THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF NEED. AND TO EXPAND IT
SO THAT WE ARE LESS INCLINED TO
SEE KIDS BECAUSE OF HOW WE'VE
CATEGORIZED THEM BUT OTHER THAN
THAT MEET KIDS. AS THEY NEED US
TO SUPPORT THEM AND PROVIDE
THOSE SUPPORTS SO. WITH ME ARE
CAN BERWICK OF THE SENECA FAMILY
. OF AGENCIES AND MARTY SAID OF
ALL THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND MONTEREY
COUNTY BOTH TO TESTIFY I BELIEVE
THEY'RE BOTH ON HE PHONE TO
SIGN SUPPORT OF THE BILL WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SOME A MEMBER OPERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINE FOR PRIMARY WITNESSES. IN A
LINE TO OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CARE CALDERON AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HI MY NAME IS DR
MARNIE SANDOVAL AND I AM THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PER CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
SERVICES IN MONTEREY COUNTY I'M
ALSO HERE AS A REPRESENTATIVE AT
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION. THERE IS
A CLEAR USE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW AND IT'S
ONLY GETTING WORSE. OVER THE
PAST DECADE PRIOR TO THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. YES THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL DISTRESS AMONG
ADOLESCENT HAD RISEN SEVENTY ONE
PERCENT. AND SUICIDALITY HAD
INCREASED FORTY SEVEN PERCENT.
EVEN AT THE SAME INDICATORS
AMONG ADULTS REMAINED UNCHANGED
. HOSPITALS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
REPORTING A 100% INCREASES OVER
THE PAST DECADE IN THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN ARE RISING IN EMERGENCY
ROOMS AND HOSPITALS DUE TO
MENTAL HEALTH CRISES AND IT
COULD ALL PRIOR TO A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC THAT REALLY HAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE. ACCORDING TO DATA
FROM MY OWN COUNTY HERE IN
MONTEREY IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN.
TWELVE CHILDREN WERE ADMITTED TO
THE EMERGENCY ROOM DUE TO A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS. THAT WITH
TWELVE CHILDREN IT STANDS IN
STARK CONTRAST TO ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY NINE USE THAT WERE
HOSPITALIZED HERE DUE TO A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS IN FISCAL
YEAR TWO THOUSAND TWENTY. FOR
THE YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
IS REAL UP BECAUSE WE DO NOT
HAVE A FULLY DEVELOPED CRISIS
CONTINUING FOR USE. THE RESULT
IS KIDS AS YOUNG AS SIX OR SEVEN
YEARS OLD ARE WAITING IN
EMERGENCY ROOMS WHERE THEY'RE%
SURROUNDED BY ADULTS WHO ARE
SICK WOUNDED DEALING WITH AN
OVERDOSE AND IN A LIFE
THREATENING SITUATION. OUR
CHILDREN ARE WAITING IN
EMERGENCY TRAUMA CENTERS EXPOSED
TO SITUATIONS THAT FURTHER
COMPOUND THEIR TRAUMA. THESE
CHILDREN NEEDS CAN AND SHOULD BE
TREATED IN A CRISIS
STABILIZATION UNIT OR IN THE
COMMUNITY WITH MOBILE CRISIS
RESPONSE- RIGHT NOW THESE
CHILDREN WAIT FOR DAYS AND A
WEEK AS A MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL
SEARCH FOR AN AVAILABLE
PSYCHIATRIC BED. WHICH MAY END
UP BEING HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY
FROM THEIR FAMILY AND THEIR
COMMUNITY AND ONLY REACHABLE BY
SEVERAL. HOURS LONG AMBULANCE
RIDE. WHAT COUNT TOWN BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AT. ARE DOING EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE WITH OUR CURRENT
RESOURCES. THE CURRENT GAPS IN
THE CRISIS CARE CONTINUUM ARE
ONLY MAKING THIS PROBLEM WORSE.
MUCH LIKE ADDING GASOLINE ON THE
FIRE. THE LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CRITICAL NEED TO BUILD OUT THE
CRISIS CONTINUUM OF CARE FOR
FOSTER YOUTH AFTER THE STATE
RIGHTFULLY ACTED TO BRING HOME
ALL USED IN OUT OF STATE
PLACEMENT AND WE'RE HERE TODAY
BECAUSE THE SAME CRISIS IT'S
FACING ALL YOU NOT JUST FOSTER
YOU'RE- A YOUNG PERSON SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO BE IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. ACCESS FEES
URGENTLY NEEDED SERVICES I'M NOT
REALLY GOES AGAINST EVERYTHING
WE KNOW ABOUT PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION. SO AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX MOVES THE
ACCESS POINT FOR THE CHILDREN
CRISIS CONTINUE ON THE PILOT
PROGRAM UPSTREAM. ENABLING
ACCESS FOR MEDIC CAL ELIGIBLE
USE. OF MY COLLEAGUE CAN BERWICK
WILL SPEAK FURTHER ABOUT THE
CLINICAL AND PROGRAMMATIC
ELEMENTS OF THE PILOT PROGRAM.
BUT ON BEHALF OF AB HDA AND
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE COURT
DESPERATE FOR THE URGENTLY
NEEDED SERVICES AND THE VISION
REFLECTED IN THIS BILL. I EARNED
YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY SIX TODAY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OPERATOR CAN TAKE SO
MUCH MONEY. GO AHEAD GOOD
AFTERNOON CHOI CALLED A MEMBER
OF THE CAN I'M K. BEAR AND I'M
THE OF. BUT I THINK OF THE OF
THE- AND THE TOWN OF AT- AND- I
AM SO PLEASED TO BE HERE TO TALK
TO YOU ABOUT A DIFFERENT AVENUE
THAT WE CAN TAKE A WIN FORWARD
TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS THAT
MONEY JUST PROP FORWARD SO WELL.
THROUGH ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONES
LEADERSHIP- LAST YEAR WE WERE
ABLE TO FOR WITH A CONTINUAL AND
THAT HAVE BEEN WORKED ON BY THE
CALIFORNIA CHILD WELFARE COUNCIL
AND PRIOR TO THAT WELL YOU CAN
BEING- STATEWIDE OF LEADERS FOR
HIGH NEED TO- ABOUT WHAT WERE
THE CRISIS CONTINUING LOOK LIKE
THEY COULD EFFECTIVELY A DRAFT-
AND NOT JUST IN IN IN HOSPITALS.
BUT IN PREVENTION IN CRISIS
INTERVENTION AND STEPPED DOWN A
MORE COMPREHENSIVE CLINICAL
APPROACH TO THE NEEDS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE AND WE WERE ABLE TO PULL
WITH THAT CONTINUUM BECAUSE OF
SO MUCH GREAT WORK BY SO MANY
LEADERS ACROSS THE STATE- AND
MOVE FORWARD A CONTINUUM FOR
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE AND
JUVENILE JUSTICE. AND THAT'S A
GREAT IDEA BUT IT'S ALSO A BAD
IDEA BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO
CREATE AVENUES FOR SUPPORT THAT
REQUIRE ENTRANCE IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE OUR ENTRANCE INTO FOSTER
CARE IN ORDER TO ACCESS SERVICES
FOR THIS BILL CORRECT THAT
INEQUITY THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD
THE IDEA THAT A COMPREHENSIVE
SYSTEM CAN BE AVAILABLE FOR YOU.
AT THE POINT OF CRISIS WHEN THEY
NEED IT AND CAN HELP THEM PRIOR
TO CRISIS TO THE FROM CRISIS
WHEN THEY ARE IN A CRISIS AND AS
THEY TRANSITION OUT WE WOULD
NEVER CREATE A PHYSICAL
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THAT HAD A
HOSPITAL WITHOUT AN EMERGENCY
ROOM- OR HAD AN EMERGENCY ROOM
WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO STEP DOWN
NOR WOULD WE EVER CREATE. A
PHYSICAL HEALTH SYSTEM THAT SAID
THAT YOU CAN'T GO TO A PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIAN OR HAVE A CRISIS. INTERVENTION IN THE HOME OR
COMMUNITY WITHOUT A GOING TO A
HOT BUT THAT A- WHAT WE DONE AND
THEN HEALTH WE COULD INSIST.
THAT THE MOVE KIDS TO EMERGENCY
ROOM WITH ALONG WITH PERIOD FOR
THE WAY WENT DON'T FOR TO THE
CORE. THE AND- CAN'T WE MADE
THEIR NEEDS AND UP ONE. TO THEM
EVER TO A- EMERGENCY FORMER ROOM. THIS CONTINUING PROVIDE
INTENSE COMMITTEE BASED FOURTH-
SUPPORT SUCH AS RESP AND- WITH
THE CORE. SHAFT THEY CAN SUPPORT
EACH. IN READ. AND VISITS TO
EMERGENCY. CRISIS STABILIZATION
UNITS FOR YOU CAN BE ASSESSED.
AND PUT A PLAN MADE AND
DISCHARGED WITHOUT NECESSARILY
ENTERING A HOSPITAL OR IF THEY
DO A FULL RANGE OF COMMUNITY
BASED INTENSIVE PLACEMENT
OPTIONS. SO THAT THEY CAN STEP
DOWN- FROM HSPITAL WITHOUT
UNNECESSARY- A LONG LENGTH OF
STAY BECAUSE THERE ARE OPTIONS
FOR DISCHARGE WE HAVE A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY IN THIS MOMENT
BECAUSE WE HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING
OF THE PROBLEM. VERY BROAD
CONSENSUS ON WHAT WE NEED TO DO
TO ADDRESSES AND TO THE STRONG
BASIC PRACTICE MODEL ALL WE NEED
TO DO IS AN ACT OF THE
POLLUTION. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU L.
OKAY WILL GO- PRIME SUPER
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT IN THE ROOM
DO WE HAVE ANY. SUPPORT IN THE
ROOM. SCENE NINE OPERATOR WOULD
YOU PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES
FOR A PUBLIC SUPPORT- AB TWO
SEVEN EIGHT SIX. THANK YOU AND
IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN EIGHT SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. WE WILL GO TO LINE OUT
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I MEAN IT'S A WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AGENCY IN THE
PORT. THANK YOU. AND WEBER LINE
TWELVE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS JANE CAN- WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN FORT. THANK YOU.
THERE'S NOTHING THERE THE
DISPENSING CUE THANK HILL OKAY I
DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM TO AB TWO SEVEN EIGHT SIX.
OKAY SEE NINE OPERATOR COULD
YOU- LET ME KNOW IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN Q. TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU A
PAIR POSTED AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. AND NO ONE HAS TO GET UP
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SO WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS FOR
THE AUTHOR. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. NOWOKAY WITH. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SOMEONE THANK
YOU THIS BUILDS ON. A LOT OF THE
WORK THAT'S GONE THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE OF THE LAST NUMBER OF
YEARS. PROVIDING A CONTINUUM OF
CARE. AND THE PIECE THAT'S BEEN
MISSING ARE SOME OF THE MOST.
THE KIDS WITH THE HIGHEST NEEDS
AND WE JUST HAVE NOT REALLY
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF BEING ABLE
TO HAVE A SYSTEM. THAT MEETS THE
NEEDS OF ALL KIDS REGARDLESS OF
CATEGORIZATIONS OF BEFORE WE
CATEGORIZE. AND THEN SUPPORT
LET'S JUST HELP THEM THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH HERE
AT LEAST WITH THE SECTION OF
KIDS WITH THE HIGHEST NEEDS ARE
ASKED HERE ABOUT. THANK YOU AT
PLEASE CALL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE CALDERON. HI CALDERON
AYE DAVIES. DAVIS I. ARAMBULA
BONTA AYE BONTA AYE BRIAN BRIAN
IS STONE STONE IV ABUJA. YOU PUT
OUT I WALDRON. OKAY MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE READ
THE BILLS ON CONSENT. FILE ITEM
TO AB TWO NINE FOUR FIVE
ARAMBULA FILE ITEM THREE AB TWO
TWO FIVE NINE BERMAN FILE ITEM
FOR AB TWO SEVEN ONE ONE
CALDERON EIGHT FILE ITEM SEVEN
AB TWO FIVE ZERO TWO CERVANTES
FILE ITEM EIGHT AB ONE EIGHT TWO
EIGHT CHEN FILE ITEM TWELVE AB
TWO THREE NINE TWO MAYES. FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWO ONE THREE
ONE MULLIN FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB
TWO EIGHT TWO SEVEN QUIRK-SILVA
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB ONE EIGHT
SIX TWO RAMOS FILE ITEM SIXTEEN
AB TWO TWO SEVEN SEVEN REYES.
THANK YOU. FOR A SECOND SECOND.
OKAY ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CALDERON AYE CALDERON AYE DAVIES
DAVIES I ARAMBULA BONTA. BONTA I
BRIAN. BRIAN ICE STONE STONE IV
ABUJA THE ABUJA I WALDRON. RATE
OKAY NOW WE'RE GONNA LET THE
CALLS SO MEMBERS CAN ADD ON.
FILE ITEM ONE AB TWO ONE FIVE
THREE CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN TO
ZERO WALDRON.
OKAY WE NEED TO VERIFY THAT. BUT
ASSEMBLY JUST WE NEED A SECOND.
THANK YOU. WITH A SECOND. FOR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
CALDERON CALDERON I'D DAVIES
DAVIES I ARAMBULA BONTA BONTA HI
BRIAN BRIAN I STONE STONE I THE
ABUJA THE ABUJA I WALDRON. FILE
ITEM SIX A. B. TWO FOUR SIX SIX
CURRENT VOTED SIX TO ZERO
ARAMBULA. WALDRON. OKAY FOR FILE
ITEM NINE WE NEED A MOTION WHICH
IS. AB THREE THREE OF SIX. WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND A
SECOND OKAY. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CALDERON. CALDERON AYE
DAVIES DAVIES I ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BONTA BONTA HI
BRIAN BRIAN AYE STONE STONE IV
ABUJA THE ABUJA I WALDRON. FILE
ITEM TEN AB TWO ONE EIGHT NINE
CURRENT VOTERS FIVE TWO ZERO
CALDERON CALDERON AYE ARAMBULA
REGULAR HIGH WALDRON. EARNED
VOTE SEVEN ZERO. OKAY AND FILE
ITEM ELEVEN. AB TWO TWENTY TO
THIRTY. THANK YOU. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CALDERON HI WALDRON
I'D DAVIES DAVIES NOW ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI BONTA. BONTA I BRIAN
BRIAN AYE STONE AYE STONE AYE
THE ABUJA THE ABUJA I WALDRON.
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB TWO SIX
TWO EIGHT CURRENT VOTE SEVEN TO
ZERO WALDRON. FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
CURRENT VOTE SIX TO ONE WALDRON. FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB TWO
EIGHT ZERO SIX CURRENT VOTE SIX
TO ZERO ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I
WALDRON. CURRENT VOTE SOME OF
HIS ERA. FILE ITEM TWENTY AB TWO
SEVEN EIGHT SIX CURRENT VOTE SIX
TO ZERO ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA HI
CURRENT BID SEVEN IS THERE. FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE AB TWO ZERO FOUR
TWO. I NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
CALDERON AYE CALDERON AYE DAVIES
DAVIES I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I'D
BONTA BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN AYE
STONE AYE STONE AYE- UDAH. AYE
WALDRON.
WHAT. UP ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I. CURRENT
VOTE. SEVEN ZERO. FILE ITEM FIVE
AB TWO SIX SIX FIVE CURRENT VOTE
SIX TO ZERO ARAMBULA RAM YOU ARE
A CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO. FILE
ITEM SIX A. B. TWO FOUR SIX SIX
CURRENT VOTE SIX TO ZERO
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I. FIND
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR TEN MINUTES- WILL WE
WAIT FOR ASSEMBLYWOMAN MARIE
WALDRON. THANK YOU.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR COMING
COMING OVER OKAY GO AHEAD. ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR KERN VOTE
SEVEN TO ZERO WALDRON. WALDRON
AYE FINAL VOTE EIGHT TWO ZERO.
FILE ITEM ONE AB TWO ONE FIVE
THREE CURRENT VOTE SEVEN TO ZERO
WALDRON WALDRON I FINAL VOTE
EIGHT ZERO. FILE ITEM FIVE AB
TWO SIX SIX FIVE CURRENT VOTE
SEVEN TO ZERO WALDRON. WALDRON I
FINAL VOTE EIGHT TWO ZERO. FILE
ITEM SIX A. B. TWO FOUR SIX SIX
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN TO ZERO
WALDRON WALDRON AYE FINAL VOTE
EIGHT ZERO. FILE ITEM NINE AB
TWO THREE ZERO SIX CURRENT VOTE
SEVEN TO ZERO WALDRON WALDRON
AYE FINAL VOTE EIGHT TWO ZERO.
FILE ITEM TEN AB TWO ONE EIGHT
NINE CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE FINAL VOTE
EIGHT TWO ZERO. FILE ITEM ELEVEN
AB TWO TWO THREE ZERO CURRENT
VOTE SIX TO ONE WALDRON. WALDRON
NOT VOTING FINAL VOTE SIX TO ONE
. FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB TWO SIX
TWO H. CURRENT VOTE SEVEN TO
ZERO WALDRON. WALDRON AYE FINAL
VOTE EIGHT TWO ZERO. FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN AB ONE SEVEN TWO EIGHT
CURRENT VOTE SIX TO ONE WALDRON.
WALDRON NO FINAL VOTE SIX TO TWO
. FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB TWO
EIGHT ZERO SIX CURRENT VOTE
SEVEN TO ZERO WALDRON WALDRON
AYE FINAL VOTE EIGHT TWO ZERO.
FILE ITEM TWENTY AB TWO SEVEN
EIGHT SIX CURRENT VOTE SEVEN TO
ZERO WALDRON. WALDRON AYE FINAL
VOTE EIGHT TWO ZERO. FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TWO ZERO FOUR
TWO CURRENT VOTE SEVEN TO ZERO
WALDRON WALDRON AYE FINAL VOTE
EIGHT TO ZERO. HEY THIS INCLUDE
THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE.